So, eine Runde Corona-Verbreiten ins Mikrofon.
So, wer ist denn schon am Start? Ihr seht schon, Twitch ist der Meinung, sechs Leute gucken zu.
Das ist quasi das Gegenstück zu den Subbox-Campern früher auf YouTube.
Oh, ich sehe gerade, ich muss unbedingt noch den Sound einstellen.
Das stimmt wieder nicht, weil Teams wieder den Sound umgestellt hat.
Teams hat wieder den Sound umgestellt. Perfekt.
Der owl-lukas, hat owl was mit der Overwatch League zu tun oder ist das eher die Eule?
Ich würde sagen, es ist eher die Eule, oder?
Eule, ey, kann ja sein. Ich habe ja viel Overwatch gemacht,
früher, dass die einen anderen Overwatch-Spezialisten am Start bin.
Bin ich der erste? Ja, ist ja mittlerweile, früher war es wahrscheinlich gar kein Thema.
Da hat keiner an eine Overwatch League gedacht, aber macht ihr nichts draus, bald ist es vorbei
und dann denkt keiner mehr an die Overwatch League. Das Ding ist ja schon mehr oder weniger dead.
Dom PC, Dankeschön für den Sub. 13 Monate, das ist ja ein richtig echter Neuer.
Heute stimmt nicht, by the way. Wir wachen heute nicht auf.
Wir sind schon aufgewacht, hoffe ich. Seid ihr wach?
Auf und mal, ne?
69 Zuschauer. Nice.
Was wir heute machen, ja, das muss ich jetzt mal kurz erklären.
Du kannst ja nur überlegen, ob du das schaffst, in einem Kommando zusammenzufassen.
Also, was wir heute machen, ist folgendes. Musik zum Beispiel, Tickenleiser, wartet mal.
Okay, also, was wir heute machen, ist, aber, Alter, das übertreibt man nicht,
Leute, das wird ja immer abgedrehter. Also, was wir heute machen, es steht ja schon im Titel.
Wir bauen heute einen Sensor für meinen Kühlschrank, aber nicht so einfach,
wie man sich das vorstellt. Chat, habt ihr eine Idee, was könnte man denn sensen wollen
von so einem Kühlschrank? Mal gucken, ob sich die high IQ Subs gelohnt haben.
Was könnte an Sensorwerten für einen Kühlschrank interessant sein?
Tür offen, ja, ist eine gute Idee. Nee, Inhalt kriegen wir damit nicht,
Temperatur auch. Stromverbrauch, ja, gute Idee. Ich sehe schon, der Chat, also,
die vielen Subs haben sich gelohnt. Massive IQ. Also, worauf wir uns heute konzentrieren ist,
Licht und Temperatur. Weil an Licht erkennt man, ob die Tür offen ist,
ohne dass man einen Türsensor braucht. Man kann nämlich einen Türsensor bei den meisten
Kühlschränken nicht so schön anbringen. Es geht, aber je nach Kühlschrank,
Bauform mit so halbrunden Türen und so ist es nicht so schön. Licht und Temperatur.
Was mein Server stellt, alle Minute mehrere Anfragen an eine bestimmte Internetseite.
Ja, Windows deinstallieren und Linux Server verwenden. Ansonsten, wenn das dein Server ist,
du kannst einen TCP-Dump machen und schauen, was genau passiert.
Okay, es ist gar nicht so einfach, es rauszubekommen, von welchem Programm exakt das jetzt kommt.
Das geht garantiert auch irgendwie, aber da müsst ihr mich erstmal schlau machen.
Also, ich zeige euch mal, was wir heute machen. Also, auf der einen Seite habe ich mir ESP32
neue Boards bestellt. Nämlich ein paar D1 Minis. Die sind nicht so klein wie die anderen,
aber die sind auch klein. Und übrigens, Leute, wo wir gerade dabei sind. Twitter.
Als erstes, als erstes. 13, dankeschön. 18 Monate. Massive Subscription. Huge Hyper-Sub.
18 Monate. Massive Poggers. Und noch einer hier. Vanilleeis 2109. 200 Jahre voraus.
3 Monate, dankeschön für den Sub. Zauberst du eigentlich aktuell irgendwas aktiv?
Nicht wirklich, ich habe eine Weile Pass of Exile gespielt, aber letzten 2 Leaks schon
nicht mehr. Gerade nicht, so wirklich. Ist das Paket angekommen? Nein, also das Paket
ist nicht angekommen, aber DHL meint, dass es heute Morgen um 7.46 Uhr geklärt wurde
und angeblich heute ankommt, was nicht stimmt, weil es sei denn, es kommt wirklich bis 22
Uhr noch, ich habe da aber meine Zweifel. Aber es ist auf dem Weg. So, was, übrigens
by the way, Pepofat. Was sagt ihr, was ist besser, der da oder der da? Also das ist Spaghetti-Eis,
das ist normales Spaghetti-Eis, Vanilleeis, Sahne, so diese komische Erdbeersauce drüber
und rechts ist Nussbecher mit Krokantsträusel und Creme und Kram. Unentschlossener Chat.
Also ich esse beides gern, aber beides kombinieren geht nicht gut auf jeden Fall. So, genug Pepofat-Bilder
uns angeguckt. Ja, ich wollte erklären, was wir heute machen. Also, ich habe mir neue,
ich habe mir eine Board bestellt, weil es die billig bei Amazon gab. Was wir jetzt machen
ist folgendes, ich möchte feststellen, ich habe einen Stinkner, was habe ich denn für
einen Kühlschrank eigentlich, irgendeinen Liebherr, ein bisschen älterer Kühlschrank,
sowas da mit Biofrost oder Superfrost oder sowas heißt das glaube ich. Ja, das sieht
ziemlich genau wie mein Kühlschrank aus hier so in der Richtung. Und was ich mir überlegt
habe, Hyperfrost, kann auch Hyperfrost sein. Zumindest der Trick ist, ja Stripes, das kommt
relativ gut hin. So, und ich habe mir überlegt, es wäre cool zu wissen, weil ich bin manchmal
relativ zackig. Ich renne dann rüber in die Küche und schnapp was aus dem Kühlschrank,
haue die Tür zu, während ich schon wieder am rausflitzen bin. Und es ist jetzt schon
öfters mal vorgekommen, dass die Tür noch auf war, allerdings so einen ganz kleinen
Spalt und dann geht die, das Gepiepse, geht dann wirklich erst an bei einer Mindesttemperatur
und das sackt. So und ich habe mir gedacht, wäre es nicht irgendwie cool, wenn ich feststellen
könnte, aber das Licht bleibt, denke ich mal meistens noch an, ich bin mir da gar nicht
so sicher jetzt, aber ich habe mir gedacht, wäre es nicht cool, wenn man feststellen könnte,
ob die Temperatur fällt und ob die Tür zu ist, beziehungsweise ob auch Licht im Kühlschrank
ist. Da habe ich mir überlegt, wie könnte man das machen und dann bin ich auf Massive
Brain Idee gekommen, was nur möglich war durch eure ganzen Subs, weil ansonsten wäre
ich dafür viel zu dumm geworden. Wir wissen, dass jeder Sub gleich IQ++ bedeutet, aber
nicht nur für mich, sondern für alle, aber für mich natürlich auch. Und deswegen bin
ich auf die Idee gekommen, ich habe noch sowas hier, ein paar. Das ist eigentlich ein Sensor,
das ist eigentlich ein Sensor für Blumen, der ermitteln kann Wasser, also Bodenfeuchtigkeit,
Mineralien, Düngerstand, aber, und das ist doch, das ist das, worum es mir geht, Helligkeit
und Temperatur. Das heißt, das Ding ist eigentlich, und es ist Wireless, und es ist Wireless,
aber nicht WLAN, das geht über Bluetooth Low Energy, das Ding. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich
wie gemacht für einen Kühlschranksensor, das Ding. Düngerstand und Bodenfeuchtigkeit
interessiert mich nicht, die kann man nicht flaschen, aber ich möchte die natürlich
nicht mit der offiziellen Xiaomi Firmware betreiben oder Xiaomi oder wie auch immer
man sie heißt. Mit dem Licht bin ich nicht ganz so sicher, aber Temperatur können wir
auf jeden Fall machen. Ich dachte mir dadurch, dass es Wireless ist, und wir hatten auch
letztens im Stream schon mal die Diskussion, wie man gut die Temperatur im Kühlschrank
monitoren kann. Da bin ich nicht auf die Idee gekommen, aber jetzt wo ich mir selbst noch
mal Gedanken gemacht habe, muss ich sagen, eigentlich ist das der perfekte Kühlschrank
Monitor. Problem ist nur Folgendes, es gibt eine ganz gute Integration für Home Assistant,
auf GitHub, die offizielle sagt, auf GitHub, das da, glaube ich, genau, das da, das ist
eine Home Assistant Addon, um das auszulesen. Das Problem ist nur, mein Server, der steht
hier oben im Server-Schrank, also den kennt, Server-Schrank habe ich schon öfters gepostet
hier, das Teil, da, da unten steht er, und das ist schlicht und ergreifend zu weit weg.
Das wäre zu weit weg, um irgendwelche Blumen auszulesen im Hof, und das wäre definitiv
zu weit weg für Kühlschrank. Tja, das ist ein bisschen problematisch, deswegen habe
ich überlegt, wir machen jetzt Folgendes, wir nehmen nichts fertiges, sondern wir bauen
das einfach mal selbst, wir probieren das selbst zu bauen, das über Bluetooth auszulesen,
und zwar, da kommt mir ganz gelegen, dass ich mir ESP32 Demon Minis bestellt habe, die
sind auch schon klein, wollte ich eben mal ausprobieren, das Board, die ESP32 haben
einen Dual-Core drauf, also eigentlich haben die Dinger drei Kerne, das kommt ja immer
als Frage, deswegen erzähle ich es nochmal, eigentlich haben die Dinger drei CPU-Kerne,
zwei Stück 240MHz, und einmal einen Low-Power-Prozessor, und Wi-Fi und Bluetooth sowie Bluetooth Low
Energy. Ja, aber.NET Core läuft auf so einem Ding nicht, und ich habe nichts in der Nähe,
was nahe genug dran wäre, wo dort net Core läuft. So, ähm, hast du mal getestet, ob
das Ding im Kühlschrank entfangen hat? Nein, habe ich nicht, aber das ist ja für den Stream
erstmal, weil wir programmieren das jetzt einfach, und dann probieren wir das aus, und
wenn es nicht funktioniert, dann keck wait und ich range bitte. So, mit dem Staubsauger
hab, äh, der Staubsauger hat kein Bluetooth. Stripes, das ist eine ziemlich gute Idee,
du meinst du würdest hier unten abschneiden, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das Ding da noch
funktioniert, aber die Idee ist nicht schlecht. Auf der anderen Seite, das Ding hier unten
ist auch nicht verkehrt, da kann man es nämlich in irgendeine Tüte reinstecken oder so, oder
irgendwas, irgendwie in ein gefrorenes Toastbrot, und dann steht es im Kühlschrank. Ähm, naja
gut, aber schauen wir mal. By the way, wisst ihr was mir gerade auffällt? Wisst ihr was
mir gerade auffällt? Wir haben ja jetzt ein Stadia Logo hier drin. Muss einfach mal sein,
müssen wir regelmäßig pro Stream mal machen. Was ist eigentlich mittlerweile deine Meinung
zu Azure? Top. Ich, also Azure finde ich super. Man darf halt nicht den Fehler machen und eins
zu eins seine Sachen, die man jetzt hat, in Azure VMs umziehen, das ist ganz schön teuer,
und auch Azure Service, das ist nicht billig. Also, es gibt ja so, es gibt ja oft mal so
die Aussagen, so nach dem Auto, ja, wenn wir in die Cloud umziehen, da müssen wir nur
noch das bezahlen, was wir benutzen, das ist viel billiger, nein, ist es nicht. Ihr könnt
davon ausgehen, Cloud zu benutzen, das sehe ich bei uns auch auf der Arbeit, Cloud zu benutzen
ist in der Regel deutlich, deutlich teurer, also wirklich deutlich teurer, als den Kram
entweder, wenn man eh schon Locations betreibt, selbst zu betreiben, oder zumindest sich einfach
nur Server zu mieten und es da drauf zu machen. Also, das billigste, wenn man was hosten will,
ist zum Beispiel zu Hetzner zu gehen, entweder Hetzner Cloud oder die Hetzner Server API,
wo wir dabei sind, ich werde da am nächsten wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Werbung machen
für Hetzner, aber, ähm, ich mache jetzt nochmal unbezahlte Werbung, muss ich mir eigentlich
jetzt überlegen, mache ich das jetzt? Ja, ich zeig's euch jetzt, ähm, hallo? Es ist
natürlich eine sehr gute Werbung für den Cloud-Anbieter jetzt, also das billigste,
was du aktuell machen kannst, ist du gehst zu Hetzner und holst dir, wenn du was kleines
brauchst, einfach sowas hier. Das ist um ein vielfaches günst, hallo? Das ist um ein vielfaches
günstiger, was du hier bekommst, als irgendeine Azure-Datenbank-Instanz oder sowas, dafür
musst du dich natürlich auch selbst drum kümmern. Habt ihr auch so Azure-Functionen
im Betrieb? Ne, so modern sind wir noch nicht. Das höchste der Gefühle ist Cosmos DB und
das, ähm, den, ähm, Azure Kubernetes Service. Das ist das höchste der Gefühle, was wir
da auf der Arbeit grad verwenden. Nein, Azure Functions haben wir nicht. So, also, das ist
somit das billigste, was man sich holen kann, dafür muss man sich da natürlich auch selbst
drum kümmern. Das ist halt die, der Vor- und Nachteil, aber eins muss man echt sagen,
ähm, Cloud-Sachen zu betreiben, also jetzt nicht sowas hier, als sich einfach nur einen
Server zu mieten, kann relativ günstig sein, aber Managed Services zu haben, ja, also das
heißt, dass man sagt, hey, ich will eine gemanagte MySQL-Datenbank oder sowas. Das ist viel,
viel teurer und diese Sache mit, ich bezahle, also das ist ja so eine Aussage, die bei Cloud-Themen
oft getroffen wird, Achtung, Flashbang, oder auch nicht. Okay.
Also immer, wir haben jetzt übrigens Flashbang-Emote, habt ihr schon gesehen. Guck mal, wir haben
jetzt, schaut mal im Chat, wir haben jetzt, ich hab, ich hab Flashbang hinzugefügt. Sollte
eigentlich Flash, Flashbang. Hab ich mir gedacht, das ist ein gutes Emote für den Fall, wenn
ich mal wieder den Dark-Reader ausschalte. Nein, hab ich noch nicht probiert. So, und,
ah, fuck, wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben. Ja, genau, also diese Sache mit, ähm, gucken
wir zum Beispiel mal, Pricing, also zum Beispiel, also die ganze, dass diese ganze, ähm, Preislist
und sowas ist sowohl bei Google als auch bei AWS als auch bei Amazon Hardcore unübersichtlich,
ja. Und die locken dich mit 300 Free Credit und du hast teilweise Schwierigkeiten, das
zu limitieren. Also es gab schon Leute, die haben über Nacht 20.000 Euro Kosten verursacht,
weil sie irgendwelche Cloud-Dinger hatten, die sich selbst aufgerufen haben und sowas.
Aber nur für die grundsätzliche Sache auch, wo dann immer gesagt wird, ja, in der Cloud
bezahlen wir nur das, was wir benutzen. Das stimmt, allerdings nur so lange, wie den Kram
keiner benutzt. Also sprich, wenn, wenn euer Traffic und eure User und eure Aufrufe so
gering sind, dass ihr quasi mit diesem, äh, Payment-Modell in der Cloud unter dem kleinsten
Hetzner-Server liegt, dann ist Cloud tatsächlich billiger. Aber wenn ihr wirklich was habt,
was ordentlich Wumms braucht, dann ist es, managt, in der Cloud in der Regel nicht billiger.
Das hat andere Vorteile, aber der Preis ist es nicht. Und wir reden nicht von der Azure
VM, sondern wir reden von irgendwie der Managed-Datenbank plus irgendwelche High-Availability-Services,
was auch immer, dann ist es in der Regel nicht billiger, sondern es ist deutlich, deutlich
teurer. Wusstest du eigentlich, dass Azure teilweise ihre eigene Internetleitung haben?
Also das wusste ich jetzt so prinzipiell nicht, aber mich hätt's gewundert, wenn das
nicht der Fall ist. Hast du schon was mit CNNs gemacht? Meinst du CDNs? Also was CNNs
sind, wüsste ich jetzt nicht. Ach du meinst diese Software-Netzwerk-Geschichte, du meinst
diese Software-Netzwerk-Geschichte, irgendwie Computer, irgendwie Blah, Software-Defined-Network
oder sowas? Nee. Keine Ahnung. Nee, dann hab ich da wahrscheinlich noch nichts mitgemacht.
Ja. Also so viel zu Cloud-Preis-Champen. Ja. Ey Leute, ich kann nicht jede drei Buchstabenabkürzungen
kennen mittlerweile. CNN ist ein Ami-Fernseher, oder? Genau, Cloud ist immer nur dann günstig,
wenn man so wenig hat, dass das Cloud-Pezahlmodell billiger ist als VMs, die man sich anerweitig
irgendwo bei Hetzner oder so mieten kann, oder aber, bis man das Free-Kontingent aufgebraucht
hat. Was die Games da, Battlefield Leaks, oh please. Hoffentlich was Gescheites. Warte,
mal muss mal kurz gucken. Wo steht das? Sehe hier nichts. Zeig mal. Gerüchte. Quasi
futuristisches Setting. Spielt mit Battle Royale und Free-2-Play. Na gut, das ist ja,
das hab ich, das sag ich ja auch schon seit gefühlt 20 Jahren, dass das so wird, ja.
Spielt, also nahe Zukunft ist Modern Warfare, dass damit bin ich, davon bin ich eigentlich
aus. Und dass es Battle Royale und Free-2-Play geben wird, das war so, also spätestens seit
dem Warzone-Erfolg, so sicher wie das Armen in der Kirche, ja. Du musst Free-2-Play machen
für diese ganze Battle Royale-Geschichte. Das wird so wie bei Warzone. Und ich wurde
ja in meinem Video geflamet, was ich dazu gemacht hab, weil ich gesagt hab, die werden
sich ganz stark von Call of Duty inspirieren lassen. Nicht unbedingt jetzt so sehr von
einzelnen Game-Mechanics, sondern so von dem Gesamtbild, weil man muss ehrlich sagen,
also Modern Warfare und der Multiplayer waren schon ziemlich am Ende und sind jetzt mit
Warzone übelst durch die Decke gegangen. Und das werden die sich garantiert nicht aufversuchen,
ja. Das war klar. Ja, Sebiks ist in der Regel auch so. Es sei dann, es sei dann, man hat
irgendwie einen Free-Kontingent oder so, ja. Naja, okay, also. Naja, drei Buchstaben-Abkürzung
gibt's ja schon, die sind ja schon mehr, mehr, mehr deutlich mittlerweile. So, mal schnell
chat. Scrawler-Manon. The Pants-Man. ABAP. Gibt es wirklich, okay, ich glaub dir, dass
du ABAP super findest, aber, aber warum? Haha, du meinst, das Bild von meiner Werkzeuge
ist echt spannend, ja. Okay, da fangen wir mal an. Pippo-Dance. Pippo-Please. So. Also,
was werden wir heute machen? Und zwar den Kühlschranksensor mit diesem Ding. Die Sache
ist die, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man das genau ausliest. Ach ja, und auch noch ne Sache,
was mir an den, an den bisherigen, oh Moment, die Musik nervt mich. Ja, besser. Hast du
mal wieder was mit dem Friseur gemacht? Ne. War geschwätzt vor ner Weile, ja, aber das.
Also. So. Achso, ein weiteres Problem, was es an diesen fertigen Integrationen gibt,
ist, es gibt einmal die hier für Home Assistant, die ist relativ gut, aber wie gesagt, mein
Server ist zu weit weg für, für Bluetooth. Und alle anderen Sachen, die ich so gefunden
hab, die, ähm, gefallen mir aus unterschiedlichen Gründen nicht. Ähm, bei den meisten ist
der Grund, weil die Dinge aktiv, diese, also, du kannst ja Bluetooth, Low Energy, Bluetooth
auf zwei Varianten machen. Du kannst entweder passiv scannen, was quasi so, äh, in die
Luft rausgeschickt wird von unterschiedlichen Sensoren und das abgreifen, oder du kannst
aktiv die Geräte fragen. Und die meisten Sachen, die ich gefunden hab, fragen aktiv
die Geräte. Das traint übelst schnell die Batterie leer. Geiler Satz, aber man hat verstanden,
was ich, was ich meine, oder? Also Leute, merkt euch, dass das traint übelst schnell,
das traint übelst schnell die Batterie leer, ja. Und, äh, wenn man das ganze passiv macht,
dann, äh, schneidet man quasi nur mit, was die Sensoren alle x Sekunden schicken und
das ist energiesparender. Es gibt aber wohl ein kleines Problem, und zwar den Batteriestand
schicken diese Geräte nicht mit in ihrer passiven Message. Dementsprechend muss ich
da wohl einmal am Tag oder so einfach mal den Batteriestand abfragen, das sollte für
die Batterie jetzt nicht so, äh, problematisch sein. Aber erstmal muss ich gucken, wie man
den Kram überhaupt ausliest. Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich wirklich Bluetooth Zeug
programmiere. Ich hab keinen Blasen Schimmer davon, aber ich hab mir im Vorfeld schon mal
was rausgesucht, nämlich was, wo man was abgucken kann. Und zwar einmal das, äh, Xiaomi
Bluetooth Low Energy Modul von ESPHome. Da kann man sich ein bisschen was abgucken. Ey,
warte. Wenn ihr das hier schon seht, ne, es wird eklig. Es wird eklig. Und noch was
anderes, wo man sich abgucken kann, das ist eine Library, die angeblich, ähm, das alles
schon kann, aber die werden wir nicht verwenden, sondern wir werden uns bloß ein paar Sachen
abgucken. Ja, der unterstützt hier beispielsweise auch schon die ganzen Sachen von diesem Sensor,
aber ich will mir einfach mal abgucken, wie die das machen, ja. Das werden wir mal versuchen
nachzubauen. Das heißt, was ich jetzt hier liegen hab, ist folgendes. Ich hab einmal
hier von den neuen, die ich bestellt hab, ESP32 hier einliegen und ich hab hier so einen
neuen Mi Flora. Und der ist wirklich ganz frisch. Den hab ich vorhin ausgepackt. Aus
der Packung hier, Leute. Hier ist die, hier ist die Packung noch von dem Ding. Die Packung
und der Inhalt ist auch komplett auf Chinesisch. Sorry, auf Chinesisch ist das alles. Da verstehst
du nix. Ich hab die nämlich damals über Banggood bestellt. Ihr wisst ja alle, Banggood,
beste China-Seite. Wir werden mal gucken, was der Kram da gerade kostet. Ich hab die ziemlich
günstig bekommen, deswegen hab ich damals noch gleich, glaub ich, haben wir das nicht
so gerne im Stream damals gefunden, gleich irgendwie noch ein Fünfer- oder Zehnerpack
hinterher bestellt. Mi Flora. Fast. Okay, es ist deutlich teurer geworden. Um nicht
zu sagen unattraktiv teuer. Was ist denn CZ? Ist das irgendwas Russisches? Tschechien oder
was ist CZ? Tschechien. Liefern die nach Deutsch? Aber 17 Euro ist zu teuer. Ich hab die, glaub
ich, für unter 10 Euro damals bekommen. Für unter 10 Dollar, glaub ich, damals sogar bekommen
im Set. Deswegen hab ich die gekauft, ansonsten hätte ich den Kram ja auch nicht geholt.
Also, ist ein bisschen teuer. Was machen die denn bei AliExpress? Ah, hier gibt's mehr
davon. Mit Batterie, also sprich, die liefern die Geräte. Oh nice, das ist gut, schön billig.
Ah, das ist besser. So sehen meine auch aus. Exakt so. Und alles komplett auf Chinesisch.
Guckt bei Wish. Wish ist das AliExpress für Noobs. Sag ich immer wieder, es gibt keine
Daseinsberechtigung für Wish. Wish ist einfach nur für Kacknoobs, die zu dumm sind, in China
selbst zu bestellen. Wish ist für Kacks, genau. 21 Monate. Ich drücke jetzt nicht 21
mal Hyper-Subscription, aber danke schön für die ganzen Subs. Über 21 Monate, das
ist ja schon richtig, richtig her. Und by the way, so, wenn du gerade da bist, so würde
ich dem Nesebaro auch nochmal sagen, wenn Nesebaro da ist, auch schön, dass ihr euch
um den Discord und das ganze Zeug gekümmert habt. Da muss ich das nicht machen. Ist also
echt nice, dass ihr mit am Start seid schon so lange. Huge Hyper-Subscription. Gearbest
geht auch noch, ja. Gearbest geht auch noch. Nice am Start zu sein, das ist schön. Gearbest
geht auch noch, aber das ist wirklich... Kackweight. 51. Ha, die Chibaden. Guck mal,
wie die Chibaden die China-Chinesen wieder. Sie haben so ein komisches Thermometer dabei,
was keine Sau braucht. Das kostet 5 Euro, dass sie auf der Startseite mit 5 Euro stehen.
Und bei den anderen Preisen kostet es gleich wie bei... Okay, nee, ist ein bisschen billiger
wie bei Banggood, aber die Chinesen wieder, ey. Hä? Moment, Moment, wartet mal, ein Vierer-Pack
durch 4? 12, das lohnt sich ja überhaupt nicht. Die Chinesen wieder, ey, ich fass es nicht.
Die Chinergy-Bade. Guck mal, hier ist er ergeblich auch wieder 7 Euro. Iiih, was ist das? Das
sieht aus wie ein sehr unangenehmes Thermometer. Ich hab Glück gehabt, dass ich das so günstig
gekriegt hab. Aktuell ist der Kram ein bisschen teurer. Aber ganz im Ernst, wenn es gut funktioniert
dürfte es trotzdem somit der, ähm, zweckentfremdetste, aber beste Kühlschrankssensor werden. 31 Euro,
lull, lull. Oder wie man früher gesagt hat, falls ihr diese Zeiten noch kennt in MMOs,
da hat man nicht gesagt, lull oder lull. Achtung Leute, ich, ich, ich muss, ich, ich kündig
das schon mal an, das wird Pains-Champ. Das wird Pains-Champ, da hat man auch nicht Roffel
gesagt. Ich, ich sag euch, das wird Pains-Champ, was ich jetzt sage. Die Leute in MMOs früher,
die lachen wollten und besonders überheblich gelacht haben, die haben geschrieben, muhahaha.
Richtig Pains-Champ, ey. Da ist mir lull tausendmal lieber als muhahaha. Das ist so dumm,
vielleicht kennt das doch der eine oder andere. Komm Max, gib Gas hier, da bin ich ja fünf
Minuten fertig. Wir wissen doch, dass C++-Controller für mich, Programmieren für mich absolut
keine Challenge ist. Ich bin fünf Minuten fertig, wenn ich Gas gebe. Easy. Haben wir
schon oft genug gesehen. Okay, das Scheiß ist mittlerweile ultra teuer und ich weiß
nicht warum. Gut. Jetzt dachte ich mir, dass es dem Chat gefällt. Also. Wir graben uns
mal kurz hier die, die Datei. Weil das brauch ich gleich noch. Vom letzten Board. So. Äh.
Update Available. Wollt ihr jetzt wirklich so ernsthaft, dass ich ein Update mach vorher?
Ah, okay. Platform-IO-Update ist nicht verkehr, darf er ruhig machen. Ach du Kacke. Okay,
wir machen mal kurz einen Update. Das Schöne an Manjaro und Pac-Man als Package-Manager
ist ja, dass es jetzt keine drei Stunden grödelt, wie Ubuntu oder CentOS oder so, sondern relativ
zackig. Relativ zackig geht. Ja, stimmt, wir können mal nebenbei gucken, was der Krampel
gerade auf Amazon kostet. Gibt's gar nicht. Ach doch. One-File. Alles klar. Boah, wird
der immer teurer. Meine Güte. Guck mal hier. Drei Stück für 65. Royal Gardena. Gießanzeiger.
Vier Stück für 86. Also. Alter, was ist mit der Musik los? Wo hast du dein Vm-Key, Vm-Wr-Key
gekauft? Da. Bei Software Kong. Das ist, das ist irgendein Mario-Karten-Mix, was da läuft.
Ist ein bisschen Pains-Cham-ig gerade. Da hast du ihn auch gekauft, nice. Ich sollte
Geld von denen verlangen. So, mach Update. Let's go, Poggers Update. Leute, wisst ihr,
woran man merkt, dass man zu lang sich mit Mitlilungsgedöns schon beschäftigt, wenn
einem fast jedes Paket, ich sag nicht jedes, aber die meisten der Pakete sagen, was es
ist. Was es ist. Wollen wir mal durchgehen. Okay. Ich kann nur vermuten, Fallsystem-Berechtigungen-Anzeige
und das in der 32er Version, Zugriffsrechte, irgendeine AMD-Code-Geschichte, wahrscheinlich
irgendwelche Verschlüsselungssachen. So, das ist die Hilfsprogramme für Xt4. Das ist
Python, das sind Python-Pakete. Das ist Ansible, Ansible-Base. Das ist irgendein Google-Serialization-Protokoll.
Das sind VoIP-Gedöns für Python. Das weiß ich nicht..NET kennen wir alle. lib-unwind
ist irgendeine Geschichte, irgendeine Low-Level-Geschichte für Stack Traces oder sowas..NET ASP kennen
wir auch. audit ist irgendein Logger für Sachen, was auf dem System passiert. Das ist
eine Bluetooth-Library, das ist keine Ahnung, kenne ich nicht. BTFS-Hilfsprogramme, XORC
für den Arsch, lib noch mehr, XORC noch mehr für den Arsch. Das sind beides, glaube
ich, Font-Rendering-Sachen. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber das ist auf jeden Fall,
nee, das ist Font-Rendering und das ist 2D. Das ist 2D-Graphic-Library, glaube ich. Pango
ist die GNOME-Image, nicht die GNOME-Text-Render-Library. dconf ist dieser GNOME-Registry-Abklatsch,
das kenne ich nicht. Das ist irgendeine X-Server-Geschichte, sagt mir jetzt auch nichts. Also, es sagt
mir viel zu viel davon was, ja. Ich bin da auch immer überrascht von, wie viel Mist
man sich merken kann. ZSCDs, gzip, okay. Wie stark möchtest du heute flexen? Dazu muss
man erstmal flexen können. Auf, jetzt mach Colonel-Update. Und man braucht ein Publikum
bei dem sowas als Flexen durchgeht. Überlegt euch mal, bei wie vielen Leuten das überhaupt
nicht checken würden. Was findest du besser, Manjaro oder Ubuntu als Manjaro, weil ich
gerne super aktuelle Sachen hab und auch i3 mag. Ja, aber i3 kannst du unter Ubuntu
genauso verwenden. Aber ich mag halt Pac-Man als Package-Manager beziehungsweise die ganzen
User-Repos und dass das superaktuell ist. So, es hat geupdatet. Ja, darfst du auch noch
alles updaten, komm. Moment, go? Was, was will der da, was ist denn Dapp? Äh, wie ging
das jetzt nochmal? Pac-Man minus S, nee, minus Q, Dapp? Oh fuck, Pac-Man-Commandos,
Alter. Und jetzt anzeigen, was es ist. Ich such jetzt einfach über den Browser. Was
hab ich da installiert, was ist das, das brauch ich überhaupt nicht. Dapp. Was ist
Dapp, Alter, Dapp? Gibt's nicht. Hier, Dapp. Dependency Go Dependency Management Tool.
Okay, das wollen wir nicht. Ich weiß nicht, warum ich das denn installiert hab, aber es
kommt weg. Deswegen will der auch Go updaten. Nix gibt's. Postman darfst du updaten und
Official Studio darfst du updaten, dann ist gut. Ist das ZSH? Ja. Das ist ZSH. Ich hab
schon seit Jahren ZSH und kein Bash mehr. Ich glaube, ich bin damals draufgekommen,
weil ich irgendein Werbevideo auf YouTube gesehen hab, also irgendeiner, der das übelst
angepriesen hat mit 30 Milliarden Plugins und ich dachte, boah, ist das geil. Mittlerweile
bin ich eigentlich dazu übergegangen, dass ich nicht mehr so viele Plugins hab, weil
das meiste komplett unsinnig ist, aber cool ist es. Könnt ihr euch noch an die Zeiten
erinnern, wo jeder, und ich weiß bestimmt einige von euch haben das immer noch, wo
jeder so eine Powerline hatte auf der Konsole. Sowas hier. Wo man mit so einem normalen Prompt,
wo man mit so einem normalen Prompt wie ich voll uncool war, wo man Powerline hatte. Und
Powerline hast du Enter gedrückt und das hat erst mal 2 Sekunden gebraucht, bis es auf
die nächste Zeile geht. Gibt es einen speziellen Grund für Arschlöcher? Ich mache halt, dass
die Pakete so schön aktuell sind. Das ist richtig lahm. Powerline ist mega lahm. So,
jetzt haben wir geupdatet, jetzt können wir loslegen. Moment. Grad bei der Gelegenheit
nochmal gucken, ob ich aktuell einen Kernel drauf hab. Ja, sieht gut aus. Ah, nicht ganz,
aber passt. Kann ich mitleben. So. Gut. Äh. Ich hab ein Problem. Wo ist mein Platform
auf I-O-Button? Äh. Mein Plattformer auffunktioniert nicht. Warum? But why? Ja, ohne IDE. Kein
... Wie, das kann doch nicht einfach kaputt sein. Das letzte Mal ging es doch noch. Keck.
Reboot. Okay. Updaten wäre das auch mal. In der Hoffnung, dann geht es wieder. Reboot.
Ich muss wahrscheinlich auch gleich rebooten. Upgrade. Ey, gut, das haben wir grad schon
gemacht. Jetzt vielleicht? Alter. Okay. Warum ist das jetzt kaputt? Hä? Okay. Reboot noch
mal. Vielleicht bringt das was. Eigentlich wollte ich jetzt anfangen und nicht noch
drei Stunden gucken, dass mein Krampel funktioniert. Aber so ist das ja immer. Irgendwas geht immer
nicht. Gucken wir mal. Ihr könnt euch ja schon mal überlegen, wie wir das Projekt nennen.
Flora-Champ oder irgendwie sowas. Okay, ich mach den Kram noch mal von Hand auf. Geht's
jetzt? What the fuck? Warum ist das kaputt? Okay Leute, wir haben ein Problem. Meine IDE
geht nicht mehr. Okay, wir machen jetzt die ultimative Lösung für sowas. Wir löschen
einfach die Installation und installieren neu. Also wir löschen das. Wir deinstallieren
das Addon. Wir deinstallieren das Addon. Ergebnis ist es aktiviert. Build. Fuck, wo ist das
Problem? Output ist eine gute Idee. Nix. Angeblich alles in Ordnung. Ja, das ist natürlich
geil. Welches Visual Studio hab ich denn? Ich hab schon das offizielle. Ich hab das
offizielle. Ich deinstalliere den Krampel jetzt mal. Kannste einfach wieder herstellen, soll's
nicht funktionieren. Okay, jetzt mag er nicht. Und jetzt deinstallieren wir den ganzen Krampel
nochmal über die Extensions. Uninstall, okay. So, ich mach das jetzt mal in einem Komplett.
Keck weh in einem Komplett. Okay, was auch immer. Brauchen wir nicht mehr. Ich mach's
jetzt mal in einem komplett neuen Verzeichnis auf. Achso. Okay, es ist nicht nix installiert.
Jetzt installieren wir das nochmal. Plattform. Ioide. Install. Gucken, ob's jetzt funktioniert.
Ansonsten zackt halt mal richtig. Reload, okay. What? Warum? Warum ist das jetzt kaputt?
Das kann doch nicht sein. Das kann doch nicht einfach kaputt gehen. Jetzt hat es ja auch
wieder installiert. Okay Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung. Wir machen jetzt die Hardcore Variante.
Ach du Scheiße, wie viel hab ich denn da? Wir löschen einfach mal den Visual Studio
Code Config. Oh, ich hab den Kram eher. Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob's jetzt klaert, wenn ich
das neu installier. Einfach mal zu Diagnose M minus EF. Jetzt geht's. What? Okay. Okay,
gut. Ich hab nix gesagt, es geht jetzt alles gut. So, neues Projekt. Und zwar, ja Chet,
wie nennen wir das? Komm Flora Champ. So, auf Board haben wir ein D1 ESP32. Hallo? D1?
Mini ESP32 hab ich hier am Start. Cool Champ. Eigentlich auch ne gute Idee. Cool Champ. So.
Finish. Ja. Erstellen. Blitz. Erstellen. Pause Champ. Der hat irgendwelche Schmerzen und ich
weiß net was. Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht normal. Okay, doch ne, der installiert grad
noch Dinger. Das ist wahrscheinlich, wenn wir das zum ersten Mal erstellen. Wahrscheinlich,
wenn wir das frisch installiert haben, braucht es wahrscheinlich kurz. Ja, mal kurz abwarten.
Ah, jetzt. Okay. Erst mal den Gramm wieder zumachen. Das ist in der Hoffnung. Hier,
Cool Champ. In der Hoffnung, dass es jetzt weiterhin funktioniert. Da ist es. Okay,
alles klar. Der Cool Champ ist am Start. Ich bin begeistert. So, da brauchen wir jetzt noch
das Board. Das hab ich hier irgendwo hinkopiert. Warum nicht das VS Code aus dem offiziellen
Community Repo? Weil, dass nicht das Microsoft Wishlist Studio Code ist, sondern das Open Source
Build. Und das Open Source Build hat einen eigenen Community Store oder manche Addons,
die nicht gehen. Und nachdem, dass die offizielle Microsoft C++ Extension braucht, die nen Copyrighted
Binary von Microsoft dabei hat, kann ich kein Platform IRO mit der Open Source Variante
verwenden. Deswegen das ganz stinknormale offizielle Visual Studio Code. So, das Board
müssen wir austauschen. Das Board passt. Das Framework passt. Partition. Okay, das müssen
wir machen. Wir brauchen viel Speicherplatz. Der Bluetooth Deck soll sehr groß sein. Upload
Speed. Ja, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert. Das sieht gut aus. Das sieht gut aus. Main
Champ. Ich mach mal die Schrift ein bisschen größer. Eins können wir die Schrift noch
größer machen. Font. By the way, ich hab meine Visual Studio Settings gelöscht. Hat
irgendjemand eine großartige Idee, warum meine Visual Studio Settings doch noch da sind?
Na, ich hab alles gelöscht. Habt ihr gesehen? Aber meine Settings von wegen Code Size und
so, das ist alles noch da. Wie kann das sein? Hä? Hexerei. Ich hab wirklich keine sinnige
Erklärung. Führ mal ehrlich jetzt. Ich schwör, Leute. Wallah. Ich schwör. Ich hab ernsthaft
keine Ahnung. So, mach mal ein bisschen Fett. Ein bisschen Pepo Fett Code, dass ich's ordentlich
lesen kann. RL-RF slash geht überhaupt nicht mehr. Geht überhaupt nicht mehr. Okay, also
dann gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert. Ich schließ mal das Board an. Ne, vorher machen
wir ja so ein super tolles Hello World. Serial. Begin. Was haben wir hier? Speed. 1 1 5. Jawoll.
Delay. Serial. Print. Keg. Wait. Ups. Upload. Welches Steam-Paket nutzt du für die Farben?
Ich hab grad meine kompletten Wishl- Ist das nicht richtig dran? Das ist nicht richtig
dran. Ich hab grad meine kompletten Wishl Studio Settings gelöscht. Das ist mehr oder
weniger alles basic. Ah, jetzt. Epoggers vm-connecten. Upload. Jawoll. So. Noch geht das schnell,
noch ist die Firmware schon klein. Serial. Keg-Wait. Oh, vielleicht sollten wir mal ein
Delay rein machen. Delay 100. Keg-Wait. Dann Keg-Wait. Keg-Wait und der Keg-Wait ein bisschen
langer. Langsamer. Warum kein Vim? Ähm, weil die Plattform IO-Integration für Vim
suckt. Gibt's aber suckt im Vergleich zu Wishl Studio Code. Und die Verwaltung ist einfach
zu nice damit. Und ich mag die Vim-Extension nicht von Wishl Studio. Wenn ich Vim hab,
dann will ich pur Vim. Hast du schon mal ausprobiert Johnny-Five-IO? Ne, was ist das? JavaScript
Raspberry Pi IoT-Plattform. Nö, sagt mir gar nichts. Muss ich mal kurz gucken. Sagt
mir gar nichts. Oh, das ist aber ganz schön Flashbang, die Seite. Oh, das liegt da mal
im Dark Reader. Ich glaub, liegt da mal im Dark Reader. Trotzdem Flashbang. Was soll
das sein? Dankeschön Grilla. 16 Monate. Das ist ja Hyper Sub-Scription extrem. Ach, es
ist Punkt-Config-Code. Ah ja, dann ist es. Dann hab ich die Konfig noch, ja. Was ist
das für ein Vorteil davon jetzt? Moment, ich brauch Node.js, um den Hello World zu machen.
Was ist das denn? Node.js, ich hab, das Board hat 4 MB Flash, da krieg ich doch kein Node.js
drauf. Äh, was? Oh. Waiter-Line? Water-Line? Water-Line wird's wahrscheinlich heißen.
Dankeschön für den Sub-Scription. Die Node.js in Bildung. Nein, aber das kenn ich nicht.
Äh, geht das mit dem ESP32? Äh, den Kram kann man, ey, wenn ich nicht müsste, würde
ich das nicht in C++ machen. Ja, hab ich und ich hab ein GitHub-Repo mit den Basic-Settings
für meine VM. Okay, auf geht's Leute. Also, wir müssen das Kram nochmal neu starten,
weil das Ding der Meinung ist, ich hab irgendwelche Packages net installiert. Geht zu. Oh,
Include. Ja, jetzt hat er's gecheckt. Okay, also, wie machen wir Bluetooth? Wir gucken
uns mal den Beispiel-Code, an den ich mir hier rauskopiert hab, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Ähm, wir werden jetzt mal was ganz Simples probieren, nämlich Bluetooth einfach mal
mitschneiden, was hier so rum Bluetooth ist in der Nähe. Wie geht denn das? BLE-Device,
BLE-Utils, BLE-Scan, BLE-Advertised-Device, alles klar. Erstmal alles Include. Besser
zu viel als zu wenig. Lul. Gehen wir mal zwischendurch billen und gucken, ob alles funktioniert.
Muss ich hier noch irgendwas einstellen? Nee, passt. Neuestes C++. By the way, wer sich
jetzt vielleicht fragt, falls jemand Plattformer auch verwendet, warum ich C++ 20 verwenden
kann, was es leider nur minimal weniger Scheiße macht, aber immerhin, also, ich mein, jedes
bisschen weniger Scheiße an C++ ist schon mal gut. Das geht nur, wenn ihr den neuesten
Feature Branch verwendet für, äh, damit, ja. Weil die Standardversion, die der, die
defaultmäßig verwendet, basiert auf 3.3. Das ist uralt. Da ist, ich glaub, da geht
noch nicht mal C++ 17, da geht, glaub ich, C++ 14. So. Also, der ganze Krempel Included.
So, und wie scannt man jetzt? Scan. Scan. Okay. Bledevice, ich copypaste mir das mal,
ohne irgendwie einen Plan zu haben, was ich da mache. So, und ich hab nur gelesen, dass
der Bluetooth Stack extrem groß ist und die Leute Probleme bekommen, weil ihr Flashspeicher
zu klein ist. Probieren wir mal aus. Ich kompilier das mal kurz und guck mal, wie fett das ist.
Jetzt, aktuell sind wir, aktuell sind wir 11% vom Flash benutzt. 218 Kilo Byte. Boah,
fuck, Alter. Das ist ja hyperfett. What the fuck? Einfach Bluetooth aktiviert, ne halbe
Flash ist voll. Alter. Okay, wenn ich jetzt noch WLAN, wenn ich jetzt noch WLAN reinmache,
ist ja der Sketch voll. Moment, das muss ich mal kurz testweise ausprobieren. Wi-Fi.
Begin. Einfach nur irgendeinen Blödsinn reinschreiben. Lul. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt, wie fett das ist. Nix mit OTA. Na, noch haben wir genug Platz. Boah,
okay. Bluetooth und WLAN machen einfach 70% vom Flash voll. Also von einer Partition
voll. Und, wohlgemerkt, ich habe schon nicht die Default-Partitionierung, ich hab schon
das Fallsystem für zusätzliche Erteilen verkleinert auf 200K. Passt mal auf, wie voll das normalerweise
ist. Ich mach mal die extra Partitionierung weg. Mit den Default-Settings passt es wahrscheinlich
gar nicht drauf. Auf den Flash. Schauen wir mal. Das ist ja, ach du Scheiße. Überlegt
euch mal, in den Default-Settings ist es mit Wi-Fi und Bluetooth-enabled zu fett. Okay,
das ist hart. Also, Default-Settings sind glaube ich 2MB Filesystem und 850K für Programm
oder so. Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. Aber wir haben es resized, wir brauchen die zusätzlichen
Files nicht. Das ist wirklich pepo fett. Okay, aber die Bluetooth, das habe ich schon im
Vorfeld gelesen, dass diese Bluetooth-Sachen richtig fett sind, wenn du die da verwenden
willst in deinem Sketch. Geht sogar so weit, dass ich schon teilweise Foren-Einträge gelesen
habe von Leuten, die deswegen 2 ESP's verwenden. Einer der macht nur Bluetooth und sonst was
und ein anderer macht den Rest von WLAN, MQTT und sonstige Geschichten, weil es so fett
ist. Aber ich glaube, das brauchen wir nicht. Aber das ist krass. 71% voll. Muss mal gucken,
ob wir den Upload-Speed vielleicht größer machen können. Mal kurz gucken, ob ich hochladen
kann. Den Scan machen wir jetzt erstmal weg. Kann ich hochladen? Okay, der Upload-Speed,
größere Upload-Speed wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren. Ich glaube, das ist schon
mehr, als du eigentlich über eine serielle Schnittstelle überhaupt hochladen kannst.
Ich glaube, mehr geht nicht. Ich glaube, wir können mal mehr probieren. Mal 2. Das ist
zu viel. Das packt er nicht. Das geht nicht. Das ist zu viel. Aber umso schneller der Upload,
umso besser. Warte mal. Durch 2? Was ist denn das? Genau, das ist normalerweise der schnellste,
wie du den Kram hochladen kannst. Ich habe schon das Doppelte genommen. Was ist denn,
wenn ich jetzt mal 3? Okay, probieren wir es mal damit. Nein, er connectet schon nicht
mehr. Guck. Gibt es nicht mehr. Upload-Error. Tja, dann müssen wir wahrscheinlich doch
bei dem davor bleiben. Und das ist schon schneller, als es normalerweise geht. Schreckt. Na gut,
dann bleiben wir hierbei. Das dürfte gerade so noch funktionieren. Also, dann machen wir
den Kram mal an. Wie scannt man denn jetzt Bluetooth? Wie funktioniert das denn? Ich
habe das noch nie gemacht. Also, was macht denn der Typ hier in diesem Beispiel-Code,
wo ich mir was klauen wollte? Also, das habe ich mir copy-pasted. Active scan. Nein, wir
wollen kein active scan. Wir wollen passive scan. Das weiß ich. Ich will ja auch nichts
anfragen bei Geräten. Ich will einfach nur mitschneiden, was da ist, was der Sensor
schickt. Intervall 100, Window 100. Lass ich jetzt einfach mal da. Callback. Okay, wie
benutzt man den Kram jetzt? Was will der hier haben? Was für ein Ding? Alter, C++. BLE
Advertised Device Callbacks. Hä? Oh. Ich muss eine eigene Klasse machen, die erbt
von BLE Advertised Device Callbacks, oder wie? Schauen wir mal, wie der das gemacht
ist. Ja, muss ich. Oh Gott, wer hat sich das aus-meinig, wer hat sich das denn wieder ausgedacht?
Monarch S, ey. Okay, also mal probieren wir mal. Probieren wir das mal aus. Class. Ich
nenne das Ding jetzt einfach- Ich nenne das Ding jetzt einfach nur Callback. Fertig.
Beste Klassenbezeichnung aller Zeiten. Und wir legen auch gleich eine an. So. Das ist
ja auch so ein Unding, was man in C++ machen kann. So, und jetzt muss ich erben von was?
BLE Advertised Device Callbacks. So, und jetzt muss ich irgendwas überschreiben. Wie macht
man das in C++? Überschreiben? Nee. Wie überschreibt man in C++? Ich kann einfach
abgucken, einfach so. Okay. So. On Result. Serial. Print. Das können wir da printen.
Advertised Device. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich mach. Get Address. Manufacturer Name.
Service Data. Data UID. Okay, Service UID klingt gut. What the hell? Gibt's das nicht
vielleicht als String oder so? Als irgendwas Normales? To String. To String klingt gut.
Alles klar. Ich hoffe einfach, das funktioniert jetzt irgendwie. So, und jetzt muss ich was
machen? Den da übergeben. Und dann funktioniert's, hoffe ich. Nein, das funktioniert natürlich
nicht. Warum? Weil no matching function to call. Und warum? Weil ich nen Pointer brauch.
Wir sind ja in C++, hätte ich ja ganz vergessen. So, jetzt haben wir nen Pointer. Und jetzt
ist es inaccessible. Hä? Okay, was möchte ich mir das jetzt sagen? Es ist inaccessible,
da ist es doch. Ich mein sowas gibt's hier nicht in C++, oder? Ah, warte mal, vielleicht
muss ich, Moment mal, vielleicht muss ich public sagen. So. Tja, der hat hier public
da vorgeschrieben. Das jetzt? Hä? Okay, das geht ja. Was soll denn das hier bedeuten?
Public? Das muss doch public sein, dass ich überhaupt davon erben kann. Wenn es nicht
public ist und ich das nicht sehe, kann ich das... Was ist das wieder für ein komisches
C++-Gedöns? Was ist das für eine Syntax? Was soll mir das sagen? Heißt das so viel
wie, ich erbe automatisch alles mit, was dort auch public ist? Gibt's da sowas wie internal
oder so? Oder virtual oder sowas? Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das treibt. Hä? Keine
Ahnung. Vielleicht erbt das public und wird selbst public. Ja, das kann ja sein, aber
ich hab ja vorhin explizit public da vorgeschrieben. Scheiß drauf, es ist C++, es funktioniert.
Ist mir egal, ich lass es jetzt einfach. So, was ist das true hier hinten dran? Want
duplicates. Ja, wir wollen duplicates bei den Scans haben, denn der Sensor schickt ja
kontinuierlich neue Sachen. Also, wenn das jetzt funktioniert, sollte ich jetzt irgendwelche
UIDs bekommen. Von Geräten hier bei mir. Upload. Und dann mach ich den Flora Stick
an und gucke, ob's funktioniert. Wie bist du dann eigentlich auf SoftwareCon gefunden?
Ich hab, ich hab random, ich glaub, ich hab sogar im Stream geguckt nach so Seiten und...
Macht's jetzt was? Oh. Das crashed. What the f... Okay, das crashed, das ist nicht gut.
Warum crash das? Also, zeig mal her. Mal gucken, was der Typ hier macht. Mal gucken, was der
Typ hier macht. Also. Ach, has service data. Ah, yes. Okay, das heißt, ich muss erst mal
gucken, warum genau brauch ich da, warum muss ich ne Callback-Klasse erben, um's dann hier
unten verwenden zu können? Das ist mir schon wieder zu hoch, was das für ein geiles AP
Design ist, aber okay. Also, ich muss sagen, wenn es keine service data hat, dann brech
ich ab. Okay, okay, okay. Und jetzt, wie geht's jetzt weiter? Uint 2Hacks. Was? Advertised
device, get service data. Das hab ich doch auch schon gemacht. Get native. Alles klar,
okay, Moment mal. Also, was? 228 ist ja auch vollkommen klar, was denn sonst? Das ist
jetzt ein Pointer zu ner... What the f... Okay. Und das alles um Bluetooth-Geräte auszulehnen.
Wir haben noch nicht mal angefangen auszulesen, Leute. Oh, was macht er dann? Ah, das sind
die ersten, oder was? Moment, Moment. Seh ich das richtig? Seh ich das richtig? Der
wandelt... Der wandelt nen Byte um in nen String in Hacks, um dann Hacks vergleichen
zu können? Warum vergleicht er nicht einfach das Byte miteinander? Oder die Bytes miteinander?
Das erscheint mir einfacher. In.NET ist das super strange, was meinste? Okay, ich
führ das jetzt einfach mal aus und guck, ob der irgendwelche Bluetooth-Geräte erfindet.
Die Library verwendet Klassen um... Ja, ja, da hab ich ja kein Problem mit. Aber warum
kann man hier nicht beispielsweise einfach nen Lambda, äh, äh, äh, in eine anonyme
Funktion reinstecken, anstatt dass ich da irgendwas erben muss? Wobei, vielleicht geht
das ja. Moment, ich guck mal, was der jetzt sagt. Serial Monitor. Ah, guck mal, guck mal.
Also, keep in mind, das Keg-Waite muss weg. Das Keg-Waite muss weg. Ach, Sebaro, hat
das geklappt mit IP-Tables? Oh, was ist jetzt los? Resource Temporary Unavailable. Ich mach
mal zu. Upload. Hat das jetzt geklappt? Ach, ich seh ja grad, jetzt Sebaro, wo ich dich
seh. Äh, mit Patrick hab ich's vorhin schon mal gesagt, als der am Start war, wo er grad
gesubbt hat. Es ist übrigens schön, dass ihr beide schon so lange am Start seid und
der Qt-Mod höchstpersönlich natürlich jetzt auch da ist und euch auch um Discord und solche
Sachen kümmert. Allein hätt ich das wahrscheinlich grad auf die Reihen gekriegt. Allein hätt
ich kein Discord und auch keine Emotes und nix. So, zeig mal her. Macht der, scannt der
jetzt was? Boah, er scannt was. Okay, das sind anscheinend Service-IDs von Bluetooth-Geräten
in meiner Nähe. Okay, der erste und eventuell wichtigste Schritt ist genommen. Er scannt
Bluetooth-Geräte ohne zu crashen. Der Rest ist jetzt Magic, was man abfragen muss. Okay,
jetzt will ich mir aber erstmal angucken, was macht der Typ hier für super, super abgedrehte
Dinger? Uint2hex. Warum? Jetzt mal. Also entweder bin ich einfach zu low-brained, das kann natürlich
auch sein. Also 3-Head. Wahrscheinlich bin ich einfach zu low-brained, aber kann ich
nicht einfach. Also nennen wir das mal irgendwie anders da. Das ist irgendwie ID. So, kann
ich nicht einfach sagen. If gleich 0xf, was hat der? Fe95. Das müsste doch eigentlich
genau das Gleiche sein, was der da mit irgendwelchen String-Compare macht. Ich mein, warum soll
ich einen Byte in einen String konvertieren, um es mit einem anderen Byte zu vergleichen?
Oder Bytes? Oder was ist das überhaupt? Ja, 2 Bytes. Oh, es ist gecrasht. MonkaS. Wow.
0xPanicked. Okay, alles klar. Oh, Leute, es ist kaputt. Oh, oh, oh. Das crasht mir.
Oh, fuck. Das crasht mir ein bisschen viel, ehrlich gesagt. So, if das da. Also, wenn
ich das richtig verstehe, haben diese Xiaomi-Geräte ne Unic ID, die mit fe95 anfängt.
Ach so, und ich wollte noch probieren, ob man das anders machen kann. Nee, kann man wahrscheinlich,
kann da kein Lambda reinstecken. Also, das heißt, von der Idee her, wenn er jetzt hier
was ausgibt. Nee, wir machen das anders. Ich printe das mal. Zack, wir brauchen eine
ordentliche Formatierungs-Library, um ordentlich Sachen ausgeben zu können, weil Standard
C++ und Arduino-String-Format suckt. Wir brauchen lib clone-fmt. Was Gescheites. Brownout-Detektor.
Das hab ich mir auch grad gedacht. Der Brownout ist detected, Alter. Da geht er erstmal auf
sein Geberit-Aqua-Clean und scheißt ne Runde. So, eine Runde FMT einbinden. Build. Und oh,
ich brauch meine Logger-Helper-Library. Wo hab ich sie? Logger. Wo steckt's? Logger.
Exzellent. Ich hab's gefunden. Würde jetzt nicht wissen, was das macht. Das ist so ein
Mini-Helper, den ich gebaut hab, um FMT rum, dass der mit Arduino-Sachen funktioniert.
So, ich hoffe, ich hab alles installiert, was ich installieren muss. Oh, wie? Da ist es
doch. Laber nicht. Wie heißt das? Wie heißt das? Heute sagt man nicht laber nicht. Heute
sagt man mach Auge oder so, ne? Oder mach kein Auge? Oder ich mach Auge? Was sagt man
heute dazu? Lost. Max wieder komplett lost. Mach kein Auge, genau. Okay, also, wenn jetzt
mein FMT-Wrapper richtig funktioniert für Arduino-Gedöns, dann kann ich jetzt sagen,
formatier mir das Ganze. Übrigens nicht dump, sondern Format. Der Unterschied zu dem normalen
FMT-Lib ist einfach, dass das Arduino-Strings verwendet. Wie formatiert man Hex-Klops? So,
also von der Idee her sollte ich jetzt den ganzen Krämpel in Hex rausbekommen. Dann
sehe ich auch, wenn ich, also ich gebe mir jetzt alle ID's aus von allen Bluetooth-Geräten,
was heißt, wenn ich jetzt gleich den Xiaomi-Stick einschalte, dann sollte dort eine FE95 aufploppen.
Max refutes, was? Max refutes sein Space Age-Klo, Brownout-Detektor. Ja, mein Klo ist ja gar
nicht mehr so modern. Warum, warum Brownout-Detekte der und scheißt der ab? Was soll das? F, warum
kacken der ab? Wo ist denn das Problem? Was hat der für Schmerzen? Der cool Champ ist
nicht so, ist ziemlich unstable. Delay haben wir drinne für den Fall der Falle. Warum ist
das so? Ah, das WiFi-Beginn macht den kaputt, weil das WiFi-Beginn sich nicht verbinden
kann. Garantiert, garantiert, das WiFi-Beginn macht das komplett dicht, weil Bluetooth und
WiFi verwenden, verwenden den gleichen CPU-Core intern. Ne, das liegt am WiFi. Der WiFi,
das WiFi dadurch, dass er sich beginnt mit, dem ich gesagt habe, soll sich mit Fake-Daten
verbinden, versucht er sich permanent zu verbinden und macht wahrscheinlich den ersten CPU-Core
komplett dicht mit WiFi und er hat nix mehr für Bluetooth übrig. Jetzt, jetzt geht's
denke ich mal, hoffe ich mal. Brownout-Detekted. Ah, guck mal, jetzt geht's. F, D, S, fuck,
das kackt immer noch ab. Was soll das jetzt? Anzeige ist raus. Scheiße, warum kackt das
ab? Huge, huge shit. Fuck, das, warum kackt denn das ab? Irgendwie habe ich eine glorreiche
Idee, warum das abkackt die ganze Zeit. Ich mein, wo ist das Problem? Okay, das ist echt
kacke. Vielleicht sollte ich das, das Window ein bisschen größer machen. Ram-Foll. Ne,
das glaube ich nicht. Das, guck mal, das läuft zwischenzeitlich vollkommen. Was kackt
der denn überhaupt ab? Mem-Copy. Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz was gucken. Ob die, ob die
irgendwie was geupdatet haben die letzten Tage. Weil ich verwende ja diesen Feature-Pranche
4.2. Ne, der ist vom 16. Februar. Den habe ich für alles andere letzter Zeit auch verwendet,
funktioniert. Musik zu leise? Echt? Geht doch, oder? Wie ihr wollt, ich kann auch einen
Ticken lauter machen. So können wir machen, so ein Stückchen. Ein Stückchen, das ist jetzt
wirklich viel lauter. Was hat das Ding jetzt für Probleme? Warum, warum kackt der ab?
Vor allem, bei was kackt der denn ab? Habe ich mal die Scan? Soll ich mal das Scan ein
bisschen länger machen? Was ist das hier für ein True Duplicates? Ja, das wollen wir haben.
Scan Active False. Intervall 100. Z-Window. Klingt eigentlich sinnvoll. Prowner Detected.
Prowner bedeutet, er hat zu wenig Strom. Aber das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Ich meine,
er hängt am USB dran. Sollte er viel mehr kriegen. Außerdem muss ich am USB dran hängen
ohne ihn zu programmieren. Es geht ja zwischendurch immer. Wartet mal, wartet mal. Der Hex-Vergleich.
Meinst du? Ey. Ich kann den Hex-Vergleich mal weg machen. Aber der Hex-Vergleich kann
nicht sein. Das soll ja nicht wirklich sein. Fuck man. Was kackt denn das Ding so ab? Okay,
wir machen jetzt nichts. Wir machen jetzt einfach gar nichts. Außer zu return, wenn
er kein Service Data heft. Ich mach Wi-Fi klar nochmal raus. Hm. Okay, das sackt jetzt
natürlich, da können wir nichts machen mit, wenn es permanent crasht. Ha? Hat er Probleme
mit dem, mit dem Print? Hat er Probleme mit dem Print? Wait a minute. Hat er Probleme
mit dem Print? Hat er Probleme mit meinem Format? DHL Express hat es heute wahrscheinlich übrigens
geschafft, äh, mein Paket weiter zu schicken. Bis jetzt steht noch nichts drin, aber heute
Morgen stand drin, dass sie irgendwas geklärt haben. Kann man vielleicht in diesem Callback
darf man da nicht printen, weil das dann zu lange dauert und da irgendwie Interrupt mäßig
abkackt oder so? Nee, das geht. Guck, keck, keck, weh. Okay, es ist auf jeden Fall nicht
zu wenig Strom. Es ist nicht zu wenig Strom. Es ist irgendwas anderes. Jetzt mal das Format,
ja, das probier ich. Vielleicht ist mein, ist das irgendwie kaputt? Aber war's ja nett,
oder? Hä? What the? Oh, äh? Oh, crash der? Puh. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Ah, ich sehe es. Guck mal, ich hab Mist gemacht. Get Service Data. Ich
guck hier ob have Service Data und ich sag Get Service UID. Ich muss sagen Get Service
Data UID. Das mir gerade aufgefallen, als ich hier oben drauf geguckt hab. Dadan liegt
das. Garantiert. Ich guck, ob Service Data da ist. Und dann brauch ich auch die Service
data uid und nicht die service uid, weil die service uid kann ja vielleicht nicht gesetzt sein ok probieren wir nochmal aus
Hoffentlich ist es das jetzt bless rng leute
Wir wussten, dass er echt hat jemand gepostet oder was ist jebaited
Jetzt funktioniert's ok format format
So und jetzt formatieren wir das ganze als hex please als hex
by the way die datei gibt's aber was auch immer
Als hex und jetzt mache ich den florastick gleich an den da
den da den da
Wenn es geht und dann sollten wir also wenn das stimmt was der typ programmiert hat dann sollten wir
Uid sehen mit fe 95 eigentlich crashen
Erste auf ok was ist was ist es eigentlich was der hier findet
fd 6 f fd 6 f bluetooth
Oh die corona die corona warn app ist das fd 6 f
Ja das kann sein mein handy liegt direkt daneben
Und was ist ff e
Ok weiß man nicht das ist die corona app
Aber wir wissen schon mal dass das prinzipiell mit den uids funktioniert
ok leute ich mach den stick jetzt an und wir chat ihr müsst jetzt ihr müsst jetzt mithelfen leute
da sollte jetzt gleich eine
Sekunde sekunde da sollte jetzt gleich eine fe 95 aufplotten quick quick quick ice chat quickmuffs schnell gucken
Ist drin war da war was da war was war immer war immer da war was
fe 95 ok da er erkennt den stick das schon mal sehr nice
So das heißt wir können das jetzt mal ausprobieren ob der jetzt nur fe 95 ausgibt wenn ich jetzt vorher checke
Oh das flaschen dauert so lang weil das schon wieder so fett ist die firme wegen wegen bluetooth
fe 95 ok dann muss man mal sagen dieser vergleich ist ja nur wirklich total
bescheuert der wandelt das erst in den des hex das also der wandelt die zwei bites in
den hex string um um ihn dann mit fe 95 zu vergleichen anstatt einfach einfach die
bites direkt mal zu vergleichen ok was auch immer ein bisschen überflüssig aber ich
will mich jetzt nicht zu sehr beschweren weil wir müssen immer noch von ihm abgucken also ok das
heißt das schreibe ich mir auch mal drüber dass das später noch weiß das heißt alle
geräte uns interessieren nur geräte mit dieser id das ist doch schon mal gut so dann kopiere
ich mir das mal und hier unten dass ich weiß dass ein gerät fertig ist und jetzt das nächste kommt
oder die nächste message machen wir so ein ding so ok wie geht es denn weiter ich bin nicht feifett
genug ja das wird sein ich brauche mehr subs für dass ich mehr feifett werde weil wir wissen ja
jeder sub ein IQ punkt für den chat und natürlich für mich auch macht doch eine konstante draus
na das wäre jetzt ein bisschen bisschen zu ordentlich oder aus dem warum soll ich eine konstante draus
machen wenn ich das nur an einer stelle braucht nemes ist 216 dankeschön für den sub und auch
weiner excellent subscription jebaited jebaited leute aber schön dass ihr am start seid und
salkin 263 dritsch bleiben dankeschön für den sub spart ram jetzt so was ähnlich in static drin
also man muss mit optimierung jetzt echt nicht weit übertreiben aber dankeschön die drei für
die subs ok wir müssen erst mal gucken dass wir den scheiß ausgelesen bekommen sonst ist hier noch
drei stunden rum aber was ist das wieder für für eine c++ abscheulichkeit moment das muss
ich jetzt erst mal kopieren und auf der zunge zergehen lassen was macht er denn da get service
data ok ich gucke dass er service data hat get service data und dann wandelt er service data in
ein byte array um moment warum ist service data überhaupt ein string und kein byte array das
ist doch im leben kein string hast du schon vom großen ubiquity abs data breach gehört nein
gucke ich gucke ich gerade mal deswegen habe ich den scheiß nicht in der cloud laufen
deswegen habe ich den scheiß nicht in der cloud laufen sondern bei mir lokal auf
raspberry pi wegen genau so einem kack
ja deswegen verstehe ich die leute nicht die immer noch weiter nach so vielen sachen
dies in letzter zeit gegeben hat wo es auch eine kamera anbieter gab wo die streams über den
china surfer abgegriffen werden konnten von jedem auf der welt warum die leute weiter da drauf
setzen ich kann es nicht verstehen oh teddy das ist toddy das ist mir zu hoch ich habe keine ahnung
was es macht und warum ist da und warum ist da vor allem ein paragrafzeichen davor ich wusste
gleich dass paragrafzeichen erlaubt ist in c code weil es den meisten egal ist ja aber die leute
sind dumm dann sollen sich auch nicht beschweren wenn irgendwelche leute sie vom rechner beim
salami machen filmen im oder im wohnzimmer vom fernseh und sich dann beschweren dass sie erpresst
werden mit bitcoin geschichten ist halt so die meisten leute sagen sie interessiert das nicht
bis jemand kommt und sie sei es auch nur irgendwie im schlafzimmer filmt ja und dann sagen sie
wie kann denn so was passieren ja weil er ihren ganzen scheiß in der cloud macht selbst schuld
das heißt nicht dass es ok ist so was zu machen natürlich ist es immer noch verwerflich in die
privatsphäre der leute so einzugreifen aber das ist den angreifern in der regel ziemlich egal
und die leute müssen mal lernen dass sie selbst dafür verantwortlich sind was sie da für einen
kack machen und die cloud anbieter reden sich da immer bei raus und passiert meistens nix
ok was habe ich hier für eine c++ abscheulichkeit vor mir irgendein string der gar kein string ist
der aber als string geschrieben wird um es danach wieder als byte array umzuwandeln wie
wäre es denn eigentlich wenn man byte arrays als byte arrays nimmt und nicht als strings
was danke für die aufführung dass du das nicht unterstützt hatte mein twitter schon
durchgeladen was meinst du ob also du meinst dass ich das nicht verwende oder her oder meinst du
dass dass du flamen wolltest auf twitter wie dumm die leute sind smart or musst du komplett
selbst machen sonst sagt ja so was ist das hier für eine ekliche sache ich check das
überhaupt etwas was sollen das sein der der wandelt das um innen innen byte array jetzt
mal jetzt mal eine ganze dumme frage wenn ich das als byte array brauche so ich gehe jetzt
mal mit meiner nicht viel ahnung von c++ daran ich kann ich nicht einfach sagen data
kasten nach byte array das müsste auch faktisch genau das gleiche sein was der da macht das
ähnliche unterschied zu dem was der macht außer dass es kürzer ist und besser lesbar ist mich
schockt das immer noch ein bisschen dass das als string kommt aber ok ich sage ja nichts
das ist genau das gleiche wo ich den sinn auch noch nicht verstanden hat warum es byte als als
typ gibt und in acht als typ gibt ist denn in acht und ein byte nicht im prinzip genau das
gleiche ich meine es ist ein byte das beides ein byte gut es ist vielleicht eine logische
geschichte dass man sagt das geht von 0 bis 255 das andere geht von minus bis plus 128 aber
unter der haube ist es das gleiche aber so ok wie geht es weiter sensortyp byte ist custom
ernsthaft ich hätte eher gedacht dass byte nen basic type def u in acht byte ok im prinzip
es ist exakt das gleiche im prinzip ist es genau das gleiche so ok was was macht der
typ denn jetzt also support sensors also sensortyp macht er jetzt sensortyp sensortyp data to
hex jetzt macht das sinn jetzt macht das sinn dass das denn string ist dass du das leisen
kannst aber das brauche wahrscheinlich gar nicht oder sensortyp hex sensortyp hex also
data und dann wahrscheinlich ist das wahrscheinlich ist das index und länge oh Gott was was
macht er da also quasi ab index 1 bis oder ab index 2 was hat er denn da gebaut start
index 2 ok ich versuchte es jetzt mal nachzubauen so wie ich das machen würde also wir suchen
nach dem sensor ach du große scheiße was davon ist denn mein sensor ich habe keine
ahnung ich gebe das jetzt einfach mal aus also so machen wir das auf jeden fall schon
mal nicht das wieder strebt mir wir machen serial print line format wir geben das hier
noch mal aus format und zwar nehmen wir jetzt von data data index 2 je nachdem was seine
komische funktion da macht index 2 und index 3 oder 1 und 2 ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
aber formatieren wir das mal und gucken ob da was sinnvolles bei rauskommt ja in go gibt
es auch viele wirren sachen aber ich muss sagen wenn ich die auswahl habe zwischen
c++ und go auch wenn ich jetzt kein riesen go fan bin in go habe ich schon ein bisschen
paar längere sachen gemacht und es war erträglich im vergleich zu c++ fe 98 null ok 98 null
haben wir da sowas hier oben bei dem drin 98 98 null null und das ist glaube ich mein
pflanzensensor das ist der pflanzensensor ok exzellent das funktioniert wir haben das
richtig gemacht also wir müssen jetzt beid quasi 3 und 4 überprüfen ob es 98 ist und
0 ach du große kacke dann sagen wir jetzt einfach mal wenn data 2 gleich 0x98 und data
3 gleich 0x0 ist dann machen wir weiter wobei wir können auch sagen wenn es ungleich ist
oder das ungleich dann machen wir einfach einen return dann haben wir eine eindrückungstiefe
gespart ok das kommt so ungefähr hin was was er da auch macht nicht 00 ist das doch
das gleiche oder null ist null aber sieht schöner aus so das hat er das oh ja oh ach
du schatt was was kommt denn jetzt hier ist encoded has data monka es kacquait kacquait
was was so ach du scheiße was was kommt denn da jetzt noch ok wenn wir testen erstmal
ob unser check hier funktioniert das heißt er sollte es jetzt er sollte das weiterhin
ausgeben und bei allen anderen nicht ausgeben ach du scheiße ok und während er das hier
ausbringt was was was was macht er tut er jetzt ist encoded has data so wenn es encoded
ist oder kein data hat dann abbrechen ok das klingt doch sinnvoll der mal bluetooth
gestellte ja sieht sieht echt so aus ok das das das funkt noch das funkt noch ok also
was macht es ist encoded control what control frame ist was data null ok da schreibe ich
lieber data null hin data null und text kann ich nicht kann ich nicht da wieder und x08
machen das ist jetzt das jetzt binary end jetzt wird es aber massive big brain kann
man das kann man das dann als pull cast überhaupt wäre ich gleich sehen ob das funktioniert
so has data ist dann data null und und x 40 the fuck ist encoded ich muss das mal ausgeben
ich habe kein plastenschimmer ob das funkt mal ich hoffe mal dass das geht meine güte
ok also wenn ich das jetzt wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe der guckt ob es da daten
hat wenn es keine daten hat hört auf oder guckt ob das in irgendeiner art und weise
encoded ist was auch immer das bedeuten soll wir könnten mal in dem anderen sourcecode
gucken das projekt ist nämlich ist nämlich viel viel sinniger ja also viel viel besser
das habe ich auch schon verwendet aber wo ach du große kacke pass value message header
ah guckt mal hier guckt mal hier guck mal hier die machen hier im prinzip genau den
gleichen kram wieder andere auch und 40 und 20 ok 20 habe ich jetzt nichts aber und 8
guck mal die machen hier im prinzip genau das gleiche ok es ist nicht encoded es ist
nicht encoded heißt das encrypted vielleicht weil bei denen ist es encrypted der der meint
bestimmt ist ist ist encrypted meint er wahrscheinlich also wenn es encrypted ist oder keine daten
hat dann machen wir nicht weiter das klingt in der tat sinnvoll dann brauchen wir noch
has capabilities ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wofür ich das brauche aber wir machen das
auch einfach mal wir klauen das von den anderen nur dass es bei uns data heißt und wir können
das direkt zu einem pool kasten warum so großen akt wir müssen nicht mal kasten kann man
direkt konvertieren ok und jetzt ich will jetzt langsam mal irgendwelche daten abrufen
data index monka es ok also wenn es auch aus irgendwelchen gründen capability hat was
auch immer uns das sagt dann ist der index 12 und ansonsten ist der index 11 also ich
finde das ich finde das total trivial chat ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht ich finde
es total obvius ja gibt es jemand der es nicht versteht kann eigentlich sein es ist
eigentlich ganz klar easy ok index warum auch immer 12 und 11 alles klar ich baue das einfach
nur nach ok und jetzt haben wir was value type x wir nennen das moment wir nennen wir
nennen wir sind mal cool wir nennen das offset weil es ja eigentlich eigentlich ist das ja
wenn man hier guckt das ist kein index der verwendet das später als offset vom start
also nennen wir das mal offset gehört das zum bluetooth standard nein das ist also die
dass es übertragen wird schon aber das ist wahrscheinlich eher eine schaumy sache wie
die ihre daten von dem von dem sensor übertragen ok ok offset haben wir jetzt offset haben
wir alles klar alles klar offset haben wir exzellent exzellent die ifa frage ist noch
ganz gut lesbar also chat gleich mache ich da eine if schleife draus dann ist sie nicht
mal gut lesbar du musst ja leute die lang dabei ist ich leute ich habe auch nur eine
begrenzte anzahl an witzen ja die ich machen kann und irgendwann wiederholt sich halt einfach
mal irgendwann ist auch mal was los wenn ich jetzt ja noch verstehen würde was hier passiert
was ich da vor mir sehe wo ließt er denn überhaupt sender sensorwerte aus hier und ok leute wir sind
nicht weit von sensorwerten auslesen entfernt hier ließt er sensorwerte aus wir müssen nur
noch verstehen was er hier macht was ist eine if schleife dann im if mit einem go to was
dann wieder nach oben geht ist eine if schleife also guck hier label ich weiß gar nicht wie man
das macht wie macht man das überhaupt label ich habe go to wie macht man ich weiß gar nicht
wie das funktioniert ich keine ahnung wie das funktioniert so und ja das ist eine if schleife
eine eine endlos eine endlos if schleife sogar ok moment funktioniert das was ich hier gebaut
habe ohne ohne label ich habe keine ahnung wie man das macht ist ja eher nur joke gewesen
ok leute erklärt mir doch mal was was hier passiert was was macht der dude hier ich habe
keine ahnung was das alles bedeutet ok also ok constant concentration constant massive huge
concentration massive brain aktivieren leute chat also massive brain aktivieren plus chat
iq aktivieren jetzt jetzt geht's los jetzt verstehe ich kein spaß mehr also data to
hex ok das ist diese komische funktion von dem typ was eigentlich unsinnig ist verwendet
das überhaupt noch mal values leute wir machen das anders wir gucken einfach was der hier
unten braucht um um die werte auszulesen ok real value real value ist data value index und value
index easy das kriegen wir noch und value length brauchen wir ok also wir brauchen value index
value index und value length das ist doch easy das ist doch easy das kriegen wir doch total
einfach aus das haben wir doch alles schon bei dem heißt das data index bei mir heißt das offset
weil ich das ja aus prinzip mal wieder anders nennen muss und oft auch irgendwie besser passt
so das ist die länge einfach überspringen einfach das unverständliche zeug so und das
nennen wir länge und das andere überhaupt das andere überhaupt value index data index plus
drei ist das dann nennen wir das mal wir nennen das nicht value index sondern wir nennen das
value start oder oder oder payload start value start start nennen wir das mal
so so jetzt haben wir eigentlich die wichtigen sachen die wir brauchen jetzt muss ich jetzt muss
ich vergleichen was länge was die also wenn die länge 2 ist dann kann ich die werte auslesen
oder wie oder was oder was ist hier ok probieren aus serial print länge gucken was wir für werte
kriegen mit unterschiedlichen längen mein brain tut weh und das alles nur um den bluetooth sensor
auszulesen passiv wohlgemerkt ohne dass wir extra batterie brauchen das ja batterie verbrauchen
kann ja jeder aha eins guck mal die länge ist eins kommt da vielleicht noch was anderes
irgendwann zwei ha bei zwei stehen die werte drin guck mal wenn die länge 2 ist dann stehen die
werte drin ok excellent excellent real value real value ist ein float alles klar also das
heißt wir gucken jetzt wenn die länge 2 ist dann lesen wir ein real value was auch immer
wir nennen es einfach nur value ein und das startet von value start plus plus eins bis zu
values dort dann wenn irgendwie acht geschifft boah what the fuck passiert hier gerade ok also
wenn ich das also ich versuche das mal zu verarbeiten was der da was der da macht also
value start plus eins ist das also an dem index von value start plus eins also im endeffekt von
zwölf plus drei also bei 15 bei index 15 plus 16 bei index 16 holte sich das bei draus dann
schifte da im moment was holte sich da raus moment dann schifte der das acht bits nach links also
füllt das mit nullen auf oder heißt es heißt es der füllt das mit nullen auf schifft links
der füllt der macht quasi aus der macht quasi aus sagen wir mal 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 2 3 4 und das
8 der macht quasi aus dem macht er dann quasi zwei so ach du große scheiße keine ahnung was
da passiert so und dann macht er dann oder mit den werten aus data index 15 meine freize kein
schimmer ich ich genau ich lasse mich jetzt einfach mal ausgeben excellent vielleicht sollten wir
vorher noch gucken woher weiß er denn jetzt überhaupt was was ist woher weiß er denn jetzt
überhaupt was was ist value type ok was ist was wollen was ist value type war das noch mal her
value type value type hex data
value type hex das kriegt er von
data dem start index und dann zwei bytes also der start index von data das heißt ich gucke
jetzt einfach mal was da drin steht ok nur mit es fängt mit 04 dann ist es die temperatur es
fängt mit 06 an dann ist es luftfeuchtigkeit 07 helligkeit 08 bodenfeuchtigkeit und so weiter
also gebe ich mir doch einfach jetzt noch mal zusätzlich aus gebe ich mir einfach zusätzlich
noch mal aus ach du kacke ich bin zu low brain dafür glaube ich der kodan wahnsinnig viele
kommentare du weißt sofort bescheid ich gebe mir jetzt einfach mal data und data index data index
ist bei mir offset ich gebe jetzt einfach mal offset aus ich gebe jetzt ich gebe jetzt an der
stelle einfach mal data also am start aus so was da drin steht also dasselbe jetzt mal type dass
ich nachher noch in der debug aus kann was verstehe type und das hier ist value übrigens nicht
uid sondern value und dass da unten brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht mehr vollkommen obvious
selbsterklärend leute du du du du du du du du da kannst du nur mit der zeit durchdrehen bei
type 8 was ist mit länge 2
wo ich glaube da habe ich irgendwie mist gemacht kann das sein kann das sein dass
ich da irgendwie mist gemacht habe type 7 was ist denn type 7 und type 8 na passt doch passt
doch 7 ist hellig kalt 8 ist bodenfeuchtigkeit aber warum kacken der da jetzt genau noch
mal ab wenn länge 2 ist bei was kackt er da jetzt ab value gibt es als hex aus ja gut aber es
müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren oder vielleicht auch nicht genau ich ich genau ich
könnte mal nach typ 4 filtern typ 4 wäre an temperatur das ist ja eines der abartigsten
dinge die ich je gemacht habe ja hoffentlich kreis jetzt nicht mehr wir kriegen jetzt ein
value gleich typ 8 typ 8 postchamp postchamp postchamp 8 8 interessiert mich nicht 0 9
moment 9 warum ist es value 0 was ist 9 was ist 9 9 ist bodenfeuchtigkeit das ha ha was
ist das type 4 das temperatur leute temperatur 243 temperatur 243 243 was aber selbst selbst
243 fahrenheit ist ein bisschen bisschen viel 117 grad Celsius ist bei mir hier gerade im
Zimmer alles klar vielleicht kelvin
24,3 ja das könnte sein das sagt einfach das sind bestimmt 24,3 moment was macht der
was macht der typ was macht der typ da unten dann moment wo sind wir guck mal if temperature
durch 10 teilen ah obvius obvius also wenn der typ 04 ist also und type gleich x04 dann
value value gleich value durch wobei da können wir tatsächlich so was machen wie der das
gemacht hat durch 10 durch die 7 hat der chat wieder chat hat es wieder erkannt jetzt wieder
massive explod expanding schwarmintelligenz am besten kommentare was die values sind guter
code dokumentiert sich selbst das wisst ihr doch das heißt wenn jemand fordert ich soll
kommentare schreiben heißt es auch im umkehrschluss er sagt das wäre kein guter code
habe gerade in der firma neu angefangen als fisi die haben so viel glasfaser das letzte
mal als ich so viel glasfaser gesehen habe war als ich dämmmatten in trocken bauwende
verlegt habe ja zum zum glück ohne asbest 24,4 ist hier im raum das ist gar nicht so
weit von der realität entfernt denke ich weil meine heizung steht auf 24 grad also das könnte
wirklich hinhauen so ungefähr plus minus 1 2 grad vielleicht wir können es doch ganz
einfach ausprobieren ich mache einfach mal die hände drum jetzt machen wir mal die dbac
ausgabe weg also type aber mal aus und den kram aber auch aus also mal temp war einfach
gar nichts erst mal struktur kann man daran weg daran legts leute daran legts wir haben
vorher kein struktur kram erstellt ich weiß gar nicht wie man das ohne struktur kram überhaupt
programmieren konnten und und wir brauchen auch unbedingt noch irgendeinen dings wie
heißt uml also weil ich glaube ohne klassen chart kommen wir auch nicht weiter uml-diagramm
und mein mein absolutes lieblingsdiagramm wir brauchen dazu der ganzen sache brauchen
wir noch ein gand diagramm also so ein gand diagramm kann auf jeden fall schon mal nichts
schaden ok 24,3 grad so ich mache jetzt mal mal hände rum hände rum gucken ob es jetzt
wärmer wird ich merke noch nix vielleicht sollte ich mal kurz hier klären ach guck
mal guck mal leute es wird wärmer es wird wärmer ich habe meine hände drum es wird
wärmer es wird atme rein gut idee das ist ja fast schon ist ja fast schon auf boob cam
28 poggers leute ok aber das scheint zu funktionieren jetzt noch mal luftfeuchtigkeit das kann
keine luftfeuchtigkeit messen das kann bodenfeuchtigkeit messen habe ich jetzt gekillt oder was jetzt
jetzt schickt es schickt nix mehr 30 grad bäm leute ich glaube das funktioniert soll
ich mal in kühlschrank legen soll ich mal rüber flitzen und soll es mal in kühlschrank
legen mal gucken ob es funktioniert ok wir machen aber vorher noch einmal kurz dass man
ein bisschen was erkennt weil wir brauchen eine uptime uptime esp time ah fuck wie ist
das get get time ne microseconds signs since boot also milliseconds seconds so auto uptime
das kann ich mal schreiben leute ab time das geben wir jetzt hier nämlich mit aus abzahlen
wir machen auch die zeit davor so da sehen wir nämlich wenn was unten durch läuft dass
auch dass es die aktuellen werte sind bringt es äußerst nice dass mir gerade 285 leute
beim bluetooth bytes rumschieben zugucken exquisite high IQ stream für den chat heute
Abend wieder massif und denkt dran jeder zusätzlicher sub auch jeder prime subscription sorgt für
noch mehr IQ im ganzen chat also bald bald reicht der hier nicht mehr aus sondern wir
sind wirklich hier bald angekommen habe ich jetzt irgendwas kaputt gemacht aber hier ab
time 21 sekunden 23 sekunden 24 sekunden 26 sekunden ab time ok das funst kannst
erst an sub erneuern hast du ja für hast du ja schon für IQ plus plus gesorgt in dem
monat du musst immer warten bis die ganzen teile durchgelaufen sind ja mache ich ja ich
gucke ja nur wenn länger 2 ist und offset temperature die lei da möchte für den sub
ex obs falscher sub falscher falscher tone eigentlich für den sub ja und jetzt ab in
den kühlschrank oder würde auch sagen ab in den kühlschrank und danach streben was
über stadia live stream mit stadia aus dem kühlschrank soll ich gehe mal rüber und
pfeffers im kühlschrank ok es empfängt auf jeden fall noch
fast da bin ich ja schon mal froh weil ich wollte gerade sagen das ist einmal durch einen
kompletten stock durch komplette stock weg durch ich könnte mir vorstellen das dauert
bis das jetzt fällt das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich kontinuierlich fallen aber ich gehe mal davon
aus der sensor kann nicht so schnell so umschalten oder so schnell dass das realisieren dass
der schau mal mal aber bluetooth signal kann schon mal nicht so schwach sein weil es eben
angekommen ist wobei guckt mal eben hat es noch eine sekunde gedauert jetzt dauert schon
zwei sekunden mit dem bluetooth signal
guck mal es geht runter 26,5 jetzt braucht es schon drei sekunden für das signal und
es kommen auch manche signale nicht mehr an oder weil vorher ist es einfach innerhalb
von paar sekunden instant durchgelaufen jetzt kommen manche bluetooth glaube ich messages
gar nicht mehr an wie geht der akku in die knie ja der kühlschrank sollte dem sollte
der batterie nicht viel machen das gar kein akku übrigens
ich weiß nicht wie lange die dinge halten aber was wir jetzt machen hat keinerlei einfluss
auf die batterie lebenszeit weil wir scannen wir kommen wir scannen komplett passiv also
wir nehmen wir hören plus das ab was das was das gerät schickt das heißt das was wir
haben hat keinerlei einfluss auf die batterie lebenszeit
ist der kühlschrank nicht aus metall doch der kühlschrank ist aus metall und steht
einmal quer am anderen ende vom stockwerk also die reichweite ist gar nicht mal so schlecht
guck mal es geht kontinuierlich runter guck mal und jetzt jetzt kommen sogar ein paar
mehr pakete durch als vorher also es ist keine 22 grad in meinem kühlschrank es müsste irgendwie
ich habe es ich habe es ziemlich weit oben hingelegt da müssten es so keine ahnung
9 grad oder so sein ich habe den kühlschrank eingestellt auf
9 bis 5 von oben also unten ist es 5 von oben ist es 9 habe ich geguckt hat so eine anzeige
vorher habe ich noch im weg gestanden ja das kann natürlich sein wenn ich im weg stehe
da kommt da nichts mehr durch warum sich das so langsam aktualisiert das weiß ich nicht
das liegt bestimmt am sensor da drin das liegt bestimmt am sensor dass er nicht so schnell
nicht so schnell schwankungen abkommen ja gut also während der während er hier noch
sendet können wir mal weiter gucken weil das ist ja nur die halbe miete dass ich temperatur
auslesen kann wie liest man denn andere sachen noch aus also was haben wir denn sonst noch
zu bieten ich mache mal hier die types wieder an weil die types sind wichtig das brauche
man und die länge brauchen wir auch weil anhand der länge und des types erkennen wir ja
was da für einen wert ankommt da der sensor sendet ja auch ohne unseren empfänger hier
weiter das egal ob wir den neu starten oder nicht hast du ahnung von aws von aws nicht
du wirklich ein bisschen von esher wenn wenn es klaut gedönnt sein soll und ein bisschen
google also google habe ich privat schon gemacht es habe ich ein bisschen auf der arbeit gemacht
das ja bei uns auch gerade recht angesagt aber von aws habe ich gar kein plan
guck mal type 7 länge 3 was ist das denn type 7 ist was type 7 ist aha das brauchen wir
helligkeit type 7 ist helligkeit das brauche und type 8 ist moisture also der gut die bringt
nichts wenn ich die im kühlschrank auslesen aber type 7 brauche type 7 ist helligkeit
ok guck mal wir sind schon mal 17 grad das heißt type 7 und länge 3 what the fuck ist
länge 3 was sagt uns der länge 3 jetzt länge 3 länge 3 kriege ich den
wert so raus alles klar easy obvius trivial trivial so kriegt man den wert raus easy as
fuck also sagen wir mal if länge 3 und das ist 7 dann brauche ich moment wo habe ich
gebeten dann brauche ich das hier für den value so bei mir heißt das ganze value start
und nicht value index ah jetzt alles klar oder code ist immer noch die beste dokument
natürlich da sieht man es mal wieder da sieht man es mal wieder so ist es ich meine wenn
das hier nicht selbsterklärend ist ja wenn das wenn das nicht selbsterklärend ist dann
weiß ich auch nicht schwarz ich auch nicht ich habe auch keine ahnung was ich da mache
leute leute ich laber nur dummes zeug natürlich ist das nicht trivial natürlich hat man kein
natürlich habe ich auch kein blassen schimmer was es macht es geht aber kann mir jemand
eine kurze zusammenfassung geben also ich habe so sensoren hier am start das ist eigentlich
ein sensor für blumen der kann temperatur bodenfeuchtigkeit mineralien im boden und
lichteinfall messen aber ich habe mir gedacht das ist der optimale sensor um zu überprüfen
ob der kühlschrank kaputt ist weil was passiert wenn der kühlschrank kaputt ist die temperatur
stimmt nicht mehr und eventuell ist die tür offen und das licht ist im kühlschrank noch
an also der der licht sensor und der temperatursensor von diesem ding sind sind und das ganze ist
natürlich an tratlos über bluetooth ist der optimale sensor für den kühlschrank so und
das dumme ist man kann das nur mit der offiziellen app verwenden oder man liest es über bluetooth
selbst aus und um das selbst auszulesen ich habe hier so einen kleinen controller am start
mit bluetooth und wlan drinne und da versuche ich gerade die einzelnen bytes mir raus zu
holen aus der bluetooth message von diesem sensor die der ab und zu mal schickt und auszulesen
was bei dem sensor gerade angesagt ist so länge 3 so und wenn die also was warum das hier so
ist habe ich auch keine ahnung aber wenn die länge der daten 2 ist und hier hex 4 dran
steht dann ist es der wert für die temperatur wenn die länge 3 ist und hier hex 07 dran
steht dann ist es der wert für die helligkeit ich habe keine ahnung warum es es scheint
aber es scheint so zu sein ja ok dann müssen wir uns aber hier noch davor schreiben was
ist temp und das ist licht so ich weiß jetzt nicht also schwarz wenn es dir geholfen hat
ist gut aber zu wirklich durchblicken was ich mache tue ich ja auch nicht ich schreibe
das mehr oder weniger ab aus dem beispiel was ich gefunden habe wo einer sowas schon mal
programmiert hat und bastel das so um dass es das macht was ich will und versuche soweit
durch zu blicken dass es funktioniert ok temperatur temp und licht haben wir jetzt drinne moment
war tempe leute habt ihr aufgepasst habe ich das richtig gemacht war temperatur auf war
das war das 07 licht hat nicht die einer zeltes wen juckts auch immer guck mal hier licht
204 null ja null das passt die tür ist zu vom kühlschrank ok was ist typ 8 und typ 9
war typ typ 8 und typ 9 ist also mineralien und bodenfeuchtigkeit ok das kann ich eh
das brauche ich nicht das brauche ich nicht im prinzip habe ich doch jetzt mehr oder weniger
alles was ich brauche oder die temperatur geht auch runter auf 13,4 grad licht ja was
immer das für eine einheit hat gar keine gibt es nicht ich glaube nicht dass das lumen
oder was auch immer sind keine ahnung luftfeuchtigkeit kann das nicht luftfeuchtigkeit kann das nicht
also nicht dieser sensor nicht dieser sensor die anderen sensoren hier die das noch unterstützt
kann das aber der kann keine luftfeuchtigkeit der kann nur bodenfeuchtigkeit dünger also
quasi mineral in den boden und temperatur und licht einstrahlung so das heißt doch
jetzt eigentlich also die temperatur funktioniert weil ich mal ehrlich sagen muss 13,1 grad
im kühlschrank das sollte er 9 oder 10 grad sein 13,1 grad ist ein bisschen viel ok es
geht aber noch weiter runter es geht noch weiter runter der sensor ist einfach nur langsam
vielleicht ist der kühlschrank schon kaputt ja ich könnte mal die tür vom kühlschrank
aufmachen und gucken ob es licht ob licht angeht ok das testen wir jetzt mal schnell
ich flätz mal rüber und mach die tür auf und gucken ob es licht angeht
so und licht macht licht irgendwas licht macht nix oder willst du wirklich so einen
langsamen sensor drin haben warum nicht macht licht irgendwas hat es schon was hat es sich
gerade geupdatet schon irgendwie temp 12,5 komm licht licht es hat doch nicht geupdatet
oder ich muss ich muss ich muss den kühlschrank wieder zumachen leute funktioniert 152 licht
ich war wieder aus
ich hab wieder zu gemacht und jetzt ist licht wieder auf null das funktioniert ich
hätte es ja nicht für möglich gehalten aber das klappt ok wir brauchen mal vergleich
152 was was ist das luxeinheit kühlschrank gibt es da gibt es da irgendeinen vergleich
wie warm das ist oder wie hell das ist in einem kühlschrank oder ok ich hab ne andere
idee wir gucken einfach mal nach was das ist ähm warte mal wie heißen die wie heißen
die bl mi flora home assistant integration da können wir nämlich mal gucken was da für
ne einheit dran steht luxe 888 luxe gibt es da irgendeinen schönen schönen vergleich
wie warm wie luxig was ist wohnzimmer arbeitszimmer die musik ist richtig monka s ja straßenbeleuchtung
naja das kommt doch hin 152 im kühlschrank in der nähe von der lampe das kann doch durchaus
sein oder 152 licht im kühlschrank und halt relativ nah an der lampe das kann das kann
doch schon sein weil alles andere ergibt keinen sinn geteilt durch 10 ergibt keinen
sinn und und durch 100 erst recht nicht c++ lernen ich weiß nicht ob man so c++ lernen
kann was ich hier mache ich schieb irgendwelche bites rum und hoffe es funktioniert ok ich
würde sagen das funktioniert hol ihn doch kurz raus dann kannst du es vergleichen wisst
ihr was wir machen ich hole den sensor wieder und dann lege ich den hier hin unter meine
unter meine unter mein fettes elgato licht und das fette elgato ring light und dimmen
das mal ein bisschen mich würde interessieren wie weit der sensor
noch runter geht wir sind jetzt bei 11,7 grad also im kühlschrank sollten es eigentlich
eher 9 grad sein ich hole das ich hole das ding und haue mein ring light drauf
ok ich habe es hier vor mir liegen jetzt liegt es einfach nur rum aktuell es liegt einfach
nur da und macht nichts ok es hat noch nicht registriert dass da irgendwie licht drauf
ist oder so ich weiß auch gar nicht wo der licht sensor ist ehrlich gesagt wahrscheinlich
oben drauf so ich legte es jetzt mal unter das elgato ring light mal kurz an ich kann
euch übrigens das mal zeigen dass da liegt da liegt da liege ich auch nichts
ok bassloss muss ich anschalten komm mal er hat schon erkannt 13 ja gut das ding liegt
ja auch hier gerade im schatten sonst worum ok mal kurz rüberschieben dann lege ich das
mal unter das ring light und mach das ring light mal an mach schon kurz fenster zu ring
light bassloss bassloss mit aktiviert so volle pulle stelle das mal hoch kann dass es auch
ordentlich drunter steht wenn man bassloss nochmal volle pulle komm mal 783 das kommt
hin das ist die lichtheit das ist die helligkeit es funktioniert 783 und jetzt machen wir das
mal zur jetzt machen wir das mal zur hälfte runter 50 prozent und warten nochmal aber
es scheint echt zu funktionieren sehr schön excellent excellent
der sensor ist lahm ne 370 leute es funktioniert guck mal vorhin also wenn das jetzt guck mal
wenn das kann vorher war 783 jetzt habe ich auf die hälfte runter gedreht jetzt man
sind 370 passt exquisite ja leute ich würde sagen wir haben es auf die reihe gekriegt
es funktioniert es funktioniert nice ok ich muss ich muss zugeben das war jetzt tatsächlich
ein bisschen einfacher als gedacht bassloss wieder aus das war jetzt ok natürlich ist
bei weitem noch nicht fertig ne ich muss hier noch ich muss noch wlan machen da muss
es per mqtt übertragen aber so die basic sachen wir können temperatur und lichthelligkeit
auslesen mehr brauche ich ja net als kühlschrank sensor das reicht voll und ganz moin max was
geht wir bauen einen sensor für kühlschrank oder wie wir zweck entfremden einen sensor
für kühlschrank nämlich eigentlich haben wir diesen sensor der ist zuständig für für
so top pflanzen und so was zum auslesen von dünger stand und bodenfeuchtigkeit temperatur
und lichteinfall ich habe mir gedacht hey temperatur und lichteinfall ist ein optimaler
sensor für den kühlschrank weil temperatur weiß ich wenn der kühlschrank zu warm ist
und lichteinfall wenn er mit tür aufgelassen hat das ist richtig nice dass das funktioniert
ok jetzt ist das licht wieder bei null das ist auch mehr oder weniger bei null das das
das ding liegt jetzt steht jetzt voll im schatten drunter nice und temperatur geht auch wieder
hoch ja gut gut sehr schön was genau hast du in deinem server verbaut ja ich habe eine
low power intel kiste ich habe nen ein assrock sowas hier nicht exakt das bord aber die plattform
habe ich aber da gibt es mittlerweile schon ein bisschen neuere das coole ist dass die
halt nur irgendwie 70 euro kostet du hast mainboard oder cpu drauf und es ist um ein
fad um vielfaches mehr power als ein raspberry pi das coole ist jetzt ja der sensor der macht
nicht nur optimal zwei optimale messungen von kühlschrank nämlich temperatur und licht
der ist auch noch bluetooth low energy die nicht das einzige problem was ich da jetzt
sehe ist wie lang hält die batterie das machen wir aber im nächsten stream weil die sache
ist die batterie gibt das ding nicht aus für die batterie muss man habe ich schon geguckt
flora für die batterie muss man ein bisschen trick 17 machen das können wir uns aber hier
von dem typ abgucken da hat es hier auch schon mal gemacht und zwar für die batterie muss
man sich direkt attachen zum gerät und das auslesen das heißt batterie auslesen verbraucht
batterie klingt jetzt doof ist aber so weil das gerät schickt kein batteriestand mit
da fehlt jetzt nur noch ja also was ich jetzt was ich jetzt was ich da noch mache das können
wir auch zusammen im nächsten stream machen also ich werde da mein dashboard wieder drauf
machen also ich habe mir so ein verwaltungs dashboard gebaut so ein web interface und
per mqtt ich habe bloß so die doofe vermutung dass der speicherplatz nicht reichen wird
dass ich dass der speicherplatz nicht reicht für ota web interface bluetooth wifi und ein
paar helper libraries ich mein man darf nicht vergessen das ding ist jetzt mit bluetooth
schon auf 60 prozent speicher und das ist 60 prozent von der erweiterten partition schon
ich kann euch mal zeigen wie viel platz der jetzt hat für eine partition kann ich das
bei ihr einrichten ohne schiener app also don't cry so much ich habe mich damit nicht
großartig beschäftigt ich kann hier vor flashback alle ich kann dir sagen es gibt ein paar
alternative apps dafür du kannst in deine heim automatisierung einbinden es gibt zum
beispiel so eine flora card für home assistant plan status card die können sogar integration
mit dieser blumen datenbank da kannst du dann anzeigen lassen was optimal ist für die jeweiligen
pflanzen und so sowas hier kannst kannst du dann als als karte machen im home assistant
dann siehst du wie das aktuell ist dafür brauchst du auch keine keine schiener app
aber du brauchst halt irgendwas was das abruft und zu deiner heim automatisierung schickt
das ist der grund warum ich sowas bastle also am einfachsten ist natürlich mit der schiener
app aber ich würde es halt nie mit der schiener app verwenden so also wir haben filesystem
zur größe aktuell das da und zwar das sind so zu ungefähr ungefähr zwei mb
ja also ungefähr zwei mb oder zwei mibi byte oder wie auch immer man das jetzt nennt
sich k
Also sind ungefähr zwei mb soll ihr müsst euch jetzt mal vorstellen das ding hat das hat maximal zwei vier mb flash
Und das bluetooth zeug ist so fett dass das 61 prozent von fast zwei mb voll macht
Übrigens mag ich diese die die diese minimal
Partitionierung von dem ding recht gerne
Weil du hast eine du hast eine partition
1,9 mb für deine firmware
1,9 mb für noch mal eine firmware wenn du updates machen willst übers vela
Du hast 50 kilobyte oder so weiß ich wie viel das ist was sie ein paar kilobyte hast du
storage der persistent ist zwischen reboots
Und du hast glaube ich noch mal so irgendwie 100 120k
Filesystem für dateien das reicht beispielsweise für ein web interface aus
Also finde ich nicht so die beste ist eigentlich die beste partitionierung weil die fault mäßig ist total bescheuert
Default mäßig hast du hier irgendwie
1 mb flash und irgendwie 2 fast 2 mb falls ist also braucht kein mensch
Das verwende ich eigentlich ganz gerne ich meine ich könnte es noch resizen
Ich könnte ich könnte das filesystem hier komplett weg machen und mir alles nehmen für
Ota und update aber das nähe ich muss mal gucken ob ich alles rein rein bekomme was ich rein bekommen will
Das können wir beim nächsten stream mal ausprobieren im nächsten stream haben wir dann
Das update das ist das mein update
Interface drauf das ist ja alles schon fertig das muss ich einfach nur reinkopieren
mqtt kleint und
Schicken das dann an home assistant sensor
Und dann habe ich eine kühlschranküberwachung ist es nicht nice wenn das ist massive pock
Massive pock um nicht zu sagen
Und es war viel einfacher als als ich mir das einsch gedacht habe am anfang
Für was braucht man eine kühlschranküberwachung naja es geht reicht es nicht als begründung
Und nebenbei kriegst du noch mit wenn einer die tür aufgelassen hat
Oder wenn die temperatur fällt aus irgendwelchen anderen gründen vielleicht weil der strom ausgefallen ist
Also die tür das kommt bei mir tatsächlich ab und zu mal vor dass ich die tür auflasse aber nicht
nicht
Aus versehen sondern ich flitze dann immer rüber macht den kühlschrank auf hol was raus und und hau die tür im
Im weg im weg gehen zu und da hatte ich jetzt schon ein paar mal dass die tür halt quasi
Angebaußt ist und wieder aufgegangen ist oder nicht richtig zugegangen ist oder sowas
Wenn der strom ausgefallen ist dann sagt ihr dass dein home assistant auch nicht mehr doch doch macht da
Das sagt man erst fällt ja nicht immer das strom im komplette haus aus und außerdem habe ich den usb dran
Für das komplette rack
Das hält am wenigsten ein paar minuten
Inklusive access points weil ein access point
Ein access point ist ja über poe am router dran und der ist an der usb dran ich dachte deine usb ist kaputt
Die ist auch kaputt aber das muss man jetzt ja nicht so laut sagen von der theorie her ist eine usb dran
Also mein kühlschrank piep rum wenn die tür offen ist ja macht meiner auch
Was schreibt der markt der markt ich wollte mal übrigens fettes danke schön dass du schön dass du hier bist ja es reicht mir
Schon wenn es wenn der ein oder andere seinen weich findet so von youtube hierher oder vielleicht ist es ja gar nicht was er schreibt
für deine doch doch
Das video von 2013 war schon motivierend genug für mich meine eigene infrastruktur aufzubauen jetzt habe ich einen pie hole
Pie hole ein solcher und einen eigenen router auf base von open sense ja auch selbst auch mal eine weile
Das ist nice das war ja so ein bisschen das setup von 2000 nicht 13 ich glaube das letzte setup war ja ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen
2017 oder so
2017 oder so aber ich habe das jetzt alles ein bisschen umgebaut ich habe es ja auch wie du hier du sagst du hast ja auch
Verschiedene sachen ich habe es auch ein bisschen entzernt ne eigenen router
eigene kiste für smart home und für kiste für container ein paar raspberry pies und esps im haus verteilt
Dass nicht mehr alles kaputt geht wenn die große 4 e-kiste ausfällt
Stimmt wir haben ja sogar noch die das ergebnis vom stream ja wir haben uns das letztes angeguckt ich muss sagen mir hat
Edgar hat ein bisschen besser gefallen als pie hole
Genau ich habe ein video gemacht in 2013 dann habe ich 2017 noch ein video gemacht jetzt und und jetzt genau ja so sieht es aus
Ok leute ich scroll noch mal schnell über den chat drüber wir haben ja noch wir haben ja noch zeit bevor der boomer max wieder schlafen gehen muss
Gar nicht gar nicht ich habe nfc auf dem klo für den heizlüfter an machen und am bett für licht aus machen wenn ich das handy drin dran leg
Ich habe kein nfc um zu erkennen ob ich daheim bin ich habe damit mal ein bisschen rum experimentiert dass du
Scannen kannst an der tür und so aber das ist nicht so sinnvoll gewesen
Blumen marshmallow neid ist nice da bist du schneller gewesen als ich weil ich habe es noch nicht ich habe noch kein container oder
Irgendwas auf gestartet mit edgard habe ich aber vor im prinzip schon ja aber das war vielleicht im nächsten stream dann
Das was man im stream gesehen hat ne das was man im stream gesehen hat ist meine jetzt das habe ich also ist meine aktuelle
Home assistant instanz die ich jetzt vor ein paar wochen mal neu eingerichtet habe aber das ist schon die richtige deswegen habe
Ich aufgepasst dass ich nichts liegen muss zum testen im stream habe ich eine eigene man stimmte das nächste mal ich weiß nicht morgen über
Morgen gucken na im zweifelsfall tasker im zweifelsfall tasker mit irgendwelchen plugins das ist der riesen vorteil von android
Du kannst da mehr oder weniger alles machen und der ios kannst es vergessen wenn shortcuts nicht kann
So ich glaube ich habe sonst nichts mehr übersehen ich hoffe ich habe keine subs
Übersehen und der karlson 18 monate sorry ich glaube das habe ich übersehen hyper subscription hier
Habe ich das übersehen nice dass du am start bist für so lange zeit
Ja meck fly ich weiß aber es ging um nfc ich mach das ich mach grad die das location tracking mache ich über eine app auf dem iphone
Gerade kämpfe 11 monate 1 vor hyper subscription hier aber noch aber noch nur
Aber trotzdem danke für den sub m r c eu twitch prime subscription huge sub dankeschön für mehr iq für den chat
Ok ich glaube ich habe sonst nichts übersehen excellent ja so muss das sein nice durch welches video hast du es wieder gefunden auf youtube
Die teilzeitgeschichte oder was anderes weil ich habe in letzter zeit ein paar videos gemacht also einige videos zu allen möglichen sachen
Also auf dem klo mache ich das so moment ich habe ja mein bild gepostet oder ein video gepostet von meiner konstruktion auf dem klo mit nfc
Das kann ich dir zeigen wie das auf meinem klo mit nfc tag funktioniert achte mit dem shithub
So wo ist das bild wo ist das bild mit dem klo das video mit dem klo wo ist das video mit dem klo
Hab ich da schon drüber gescrollt feuerwerk da so sieht das bei mir aus so achtung
Da pappt ein nfc tag da klebt ein nfc tag ich habe mir mal so ein set gekauft für 2,50 Euro mit ganz vielen tags dran
Ja schöne ct heftchen da liegen so viele weil ich die dinger nicht lese ich habe die subscribed seit 15 Jahren oder so schon ewig 20 jahren wahrscheinlich fast schon
Ich habe auch einen riesen stapel hier aber ich lese die mittlerweile eigentlich gar nicht mehr genau nfc tag handy scan ach das erkannt das geht über shortcuts
Shortcuts an home assistant und dann geht der heizer an oder nochmal dran halten dann geht der heizer wieder aus
Was macht eigentlich dieser one liner den du auf twitter gepostet hast das weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr was ich da gepostet habe
Ach so der hat irgendwie ach den meinst du ja der hat irgendwelche proxy logs sortiert glaube ich
Das ist das was ich danach in c sharp multithreaded neu gebastelt habe was ein viertel stunde braucht und bash über eine woche läuft
Kein witz habe ich euch schon ein paarmal erzählt wir haben so den super bash hacksaw bei uns auf der arbeit der macht alles in bash und der hat eine proxy auswertung für squid logs programmiert
Der quasi zählt wie oft das aufgerufen wurde welche uhr über das letzte jahr und das lief über eine woche die auswertung in bash
Da habe ich gesagt das kann nicht sein haben wir uns hingesetzt also habe ich mich hingesetzt er hat mir mal erklärt was das machen soll und da habe ich das nachgebastelt in.net core
Und jetzt läuft es auf 12 kern multithreaded ist in 15 minuten fertig also eine woche versus 15 minuten
Und was soll der kühlschrank sensor machen der senzt schon wie du hier unten siehst der stellt gerade fest dass es hier bei mir im zimmer ziemlich nah an der heizung 23,4 grad ist
Und so gut wie kein licht auf den sensor fällt das stimmt auch der liegt da in der eck
Und ich hatte den sensor eben schon im kühlschrank drin und da hat er gesagt es ist 11 grad was busy warm ist ehrlich gesagt und licht hat er erkannt wenn die tür auf war
Ich habe dafür so einen so einen sensor hier genommen der ist eigentlich nicht dafür gedacht den haben wir da ein bisschen zweck entfremdet für
Das ist eigentlich ein sensor für so blumentöpfe der ganze bodenfeuchtigkeit und sowas mit messen aber du kannst auch temperatur und lichteinfall messen und das ist halt optimal für kühlschrank
Und es ist wireless das heißt ich schmeiß mir so ein ding in den kühlschrank und dann weiß ich ob ich die tür vergessen habe falls ich das gepieps überhören sollte das irgendwie auch nicht
Ich weiß ob die temperatur ansteigt ohne dass ich das will
Genau du brauchst dass das funktioniert dass das funktioniert brauchst du dass du das mit den nfc tags mit den nfc tags machen kannst
Ich habe schon zugemacht brauchst du die home assistant app auf deinem iphone und dann kannst du einen shortcuts job machen der bei gescanntem nfc tag also du trägst den shortcuts ein wenn nfc tag gescannt wurde
Und dann soll der home assistant was triggern genau und du musst das auf jeden fall über die home assistant action machen weil wenn du es nicht über die home assistant app action machst fragt er dich jedes mal ob du den bildschirm entsperren willst
Dann musst du quasi den bildschirm entsperren dass du die automation auslösen darfst wenn du das über die home assistant automation in shortcuts machst dann musst du nicht den bildschirm entsperren und ich will ja nicht den bildschirm erst entsperren dass ich es warm beim kacken hab
Das ist ja unsinnig ja
Das kann ich aber ich hab ja nix in homekit ich hab ja keine homekit geräte also ich weiß dass das geht aber ich ich vermeide es solang es geht
Also ich vermeide es solang es geht weil ich hab schon ziemlich viel ich mein ich hab C-Wave geräte ich hab Zigbee geräte ich hab wifi geräte ich hab bluetooth geräte ich hab RF433 geräte
Bestimmt noch ein paar dinger vergesst ich hab alle möglichen dinger also Infrarot Sachen also ich hab da schon total viel unterschiedliche zeug also ich brauch nicht noch ne plattform die ich da irgendwie einbinden muss
Ich mag ich mag mx linux auch nicht mir gefällt manjaro am liebsten mx linux hat mir nicht gefallen ich hab mir das angeguckt ich hab den vorteil nicht so genau erkannt
Also ich mach ich nehm manjaro mit i3 ich hab das hier hab ich selbst konfiguriert alles aber es gibt auch schon ganz guten manjaro preconfigured wenn du meine settings haben willst da kannst du auf github gehen
Die sind nicht so 100%ig top aktuell aber ich hab da kaum was dran geändert da fehlt nicht viel
Hier hast du den ganzen Krempel ist zwar ein Jahr her aber da hat sich wirklich nicht mehr viel getan dran die ein oder anderen Sachen haben sich getan aber die will ich da nicht einchecken weil das beispielsweise Shortcuts für die Arbeit sind oder so
Die konfig sind auch nicht lang ich mein das ist wirklich basic t-max konfig
Das sind ein paar Git-Aliasse ja die genau die Git-Aliasse brauch ich die verwende ich öfters
Also das da die drei sind meine meist benutzten Git-Aliasse COP, CO und CP also eigentlich hauptsächlich den da weil ihr wisst ja ich muss viel hotfix gedünst von anderen Leuten machen aber die drei sind so meine Git-Aliasse wo ich schon die normalen Kommandos gar nicht mehr kenne
Ja das stimmt exzellent
Ja ja genau also bei NFC ist es ja so das Gerät was den NFC Tag scannt muss das auslösen nicht umgedreht
Also du hast ja Sachen beispielsweise Lichtschranken oder so dann ist es so das die Lichtschranke erkennt wenn eine durchläuft und was meldet
Bei NFC ist das umgedreht der NFC Tag selbst ist ja komplett passiv und das Gerät was den NFC Tag scannt also es ist nicht so dass der NFC Tag merkt dass er gescannt wird sondern das Gerät scannt den NFC Tag und muss dann da drauf reagieren das ist umgedreht
Deswegen kannst du es auch nicht mit jedem x beliebigen Handy machen sondern es muss eins sein was NFC kann also im Prinzip ist das RFID aber halt für nahe Sachen
Und ein Gerät was halt so eine Automatisierung auslösen kann kannst du bei Android auch wunderbar machen aber ich muss sagen wenn es funktioniert ist es mit Shortcuts gut aber was Automatisierung angeht ist Apple halt ganz schön hinter Android muss man das sagen
Ist halt so die unterschiedliche Philosophiesache du kannst bei Android halt saumäßig viel selbst machen was du unter iOS im Leben nicht machen könntest umgedreht ist das unter iOS oftmals einfacher wenn das Leute diesen Kram einfach nur benutzen wollen
Und deswegen ich denke halt man sollte das benutzen was sich anbietet war das eine MeBodyScale ja stimmt das kann ich mal denken Moment ich muss gerade noch mal kurz raussuchen wo ich das Video habe warte mal das war eine MeBodyScale genau das wusste ich nämlich auch noch mal in einem der nächsten Streams jetzt wo ich weiß wie man Bluetooth ausliest
Das haben wir nämlich schon mal probiert vor einer Weile im letzten in einem der vor zwei Jahren oder so im Stream aber da hat es nicht so gut funktioniert
Meine Waage dass ich schön Grafana-Craft drüber machen kann wie pepo dick ich bin was trendet denn hier schon wieder oh nein nein nein nein nein es gibt Trends die will ich mir jetzt nicht angucken
Ich weiß genau wenn ich diese beiden Trends lese bin ich Triggered
Das gucke ich mir jetzt nicht an
Ja das ist eine MeBodyScale ja ja da hinten guck da da steht es
MeBodyScale
Da ist eine MeBodyScale
Und
Wir haben das ja hier sieht man so gut wir haben das ja das letzte Mal schon ausprobiert also das letzte Mal das letzte Mal ist zwei Jahre her da habe ich es mit so einer fertigen Software ausprobiert die das unterstützt mit der mit der Waage
Jetzt wo ich weiß wie man Bluetooth auslesen kann ist das viel nicer
Dann lese ich nämlich die Waage mit Bluetooth aus und am besten mit dem gleichen mit dem gleichen der auch hier die den Kühlschrank Sensor ausliest weil
Der Kühlschrank ist auf der einen Seite vom Stockwerk das Bad ist auf der anderen Seite ich bin noch mal auf der anderen wir sind also quasi genau in der Ecke jeweils
Und dann hänge ich das Ding einfach irgendwo in die Mitte
Eine Steckdose dran
Eventuell in die Küche sogar weil das Bad ist schräg gegenüber durch die Wand durch
Und dann schickt ihr das bei Wlan hin das passt ja
Ja genau das werde ich so machen das gleiche Gerät das können wir vielleicht im nächsten Stream auch machen dann wenn ich den Rest programmier
Die Waage können wir auch auslesen ja
Macht denn der Lüfter so schnell warm dass es sich lohnt klar
Das sind 2000 Watt Heizlüfter
Das Ding geht an und das dauert zwei Minuten dann ist warm im Bad
Und wenn du hier gegenüber ist du siehst ja hier ist mein Klo ich sitze quasi gerade auf meinem Klo drauf sieht man ja wenn ich hier rein laufe
Wie lange kackst du denn länger als zwei Minuten also lohnt sich das
Guck hier ist das Klo gegenüber ist der Heizlüfter
Das heißt wenn ich das hier jetzt anmache dann sitze ich ja sogar noch hier im Gebläse vom Heizlüfter dann ist das instant warm
Das ist mein Klo ganz allein da kann ich das machen wie ich lustig bin
Und der ESP der kommt wahrscheinlich in ein Gehäuse weil ich hab mir ja bei Amazon so günstige Boxen gekauft letztens
Für 90 Cent
Verteiler Dose oder so hab ich da letztens gesucht
Ich hab mir so was hier gekauft ich hab mir davon einen 5er Pack gekauft von so kleinen Dinger für 90 Cent
Weil ich mir gedacht hab ohne Scheiß für 90 Cent so billig kriegst du Wasser abweisende Dosen nie wieder
Die sind IP54, IP54 heißt glaube ich halbwegs Staubdicht und Spritzwasser geschützt oder so
Was heißt denn IP, IP45, Dust Protected und Splash of Water also sprich du kannst das mal kurz ansprayen
Und für 90 Cent kannst du dich nicht beschweren für so eine Box das ist in Ordnung
Weil guck mal der andere Kram kostet viel mehr und da werd ich den wahrscheinlich reinstecken
Das Ding braucht kein Display, das Ding braucht nix, das Ding braucht einfach einen USB Kabel den durch da druck ich mir gar nichts aus
Wippen Dein 3D Drucker
Den Heizlüfter könntest du übertakten wahrscheinlich ja aber das ist mir zu Smoke anfällig wenn ich den übertakte
Ja und genau also wie gesagt das jetzt hab ich jetzt bin ich so doof ich hab jetzt schon wieder mein Twitter zugemacht
Richtig oh nein ich will keine Twitter Trends öffnen keine Twitter Trends Max, Max nicht aufhören Twitter Trends zu lesen
Das ist immer das schlimmste was man machen kann Twitter Trends lesen und wenn ich die zwei Trends die ich eben schon gesehen hab haben wir wieder gereicht
Ich darf nicht den Fehler machen da jetzt gleich noch rein zu gucken sonst krieg ich mich wieder auf über Twitter
Das kann man machen ja
Obwohl ich ja persönlich nur noch ESP32 verwende obwohl ich noch ESP866 da habe also ESP866 würde ich nur noch verwenden wenn ich fertige Firmware verwende
Also wenn ich TASMOTA oder WLED oder so nehme die einfach fix und fertig ist und funktioniert dann hatte ich damit keine Probleme
Aber alles was ich selbst mache will ich kein ESP866 mehr nämlich nur ESP32 mittlerweile
Ist einfach viel angenehmer und nachdem C++ so scheiße ist und man eh ne riesen Helper Library mit der Zeit sich an baut weil die Sprache suckt
Muss ich nicht dafür sorgen dass der Kram dann auf dem ESP866 und auf dem ESP32 läuft
Zum Beispiel den ich hab jetzt standardmäßig meinen C++ Standard immer auf 20 gestellt weil es ein bisschen erträglicher macht das ganze
Das geht beispielsweise mit der Software vom ESP866 gar nicht ich glaub der kann maximal C++14 vielleicht ist es mittlerweile besser
Das kann ich verstehen die MiApps sucken in der Regel Hardcore
Das könnte man auch machen ja man könnte dann einprogrammieren dass es einfach immer 20 Kilo abzieht oder in dem Fall 32 Kilo könnte man machen
Aber das ist ja das stellt ja den Sinn irgendwie in Frage so ein bisschen ne oh monka reflink
Ja dann bestell doch einfach ESP32 so teuer ist der Kram noch gar nicht also ich muss sagen Aliexpress ist natürlich immer am besten aber ich hab mir jetzt einen 5er Pack bestellt
Von denen hier während DHL meine andere nicht geliefert bekommt
Das ist finde ich auch in Ordnung wenn man das schnell haben will das geht ich mein bei Ali ist es natürlich noch mal ne Ecke billiger guck mal mal was man hier bezahlt
Die Minute haben wir schnell noch Frau Socken alles klar also wer denn wenn ihr Frau Socken haben wollt Aliexpress
Okay das kostet halt nur die Hälfte bei den Chinaschinesen
Dafür steht es dann auch im Suezkanal rum wenn ihr Pech habt oder ihr guckt dass es aus nem Warenlager von der EU kommt das geht natürlich auch
Guck mal Banggood hat gar kein ESP32 demonmini was ist da los warum nicht
Ah doch hier da kostet er aber 5,27 das ist gar nicht so viel billiger aber kommt aus UK 8,6 what the cack wait
Dann würd ichs hier bestellen aber es ist halt ganz schön teuer ne
Macht ihr das 2. Mai DHL lohnt sich nicht also China kostet die Hälfte dauert halt ein bisschen ne
Da könnt ihr euch halt 10 Stück bestellen und bezahlt das was bei Amazon dann irgendwie 5 kosten
Manchmal kann man ich check das immer nicht was Schiff aus Germany ne Schiff aus Spanien müssen wir mal glaube ich gucken
Ne aber da gibt es auch Sachen nicht Schiff aus äh kann man nicht sagen Schiff aus allem außer China
Frankreich schicken sie manchmal auch Niederlande gibt es gar keine Niederlande hier ok was haben wir Belgien
Ey Leute keine Chance dem müsst ihr auch China bestellen wenn ihr einen braucht oder Amazon
Aber sonst noch irgendwie andere Chancen ebay ebay aus China wahrscheinlich Modultechnik
Kommt das aus China Lieferzeit ja hier China Hongkong Taiwan wie spricht man das aus ich glaub irgendwie so spricht man das glaub aus
Chanshan naja ja genau Chanschen Chanschen
Ja sonst hast du keine Chance den Kram dann würde ich es wahrscheinlich bei Amazon oder bei Amazon wie die coolen Leute das sagen kaufen
Der Preisunterschied ist schon da zwischen dem ESP 2,86 und dem ESP 32 aber ich finde die 3 Euro schocken mich jetzt nicht so sehr dass ich mich mit dem 2,86 noch rum ärgern würde
Ja alles klar Leute schön dass ihr dabei gewesen seid ich gehe jetzt pennen wir sehen uns die Tage bis denn machts gut CU